WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS FIRST
EDUCATIONAL HEARING OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION ON THE
IMPACT.
OF CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES ON
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OVER THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
WILDFIRES WHICH OF BOTH DIRECTLY
AND INDIRECTLY IMPACTED.
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
SCHOOL BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED BY FIRES
AND MUD.
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS AND SCHOOL
STAFF HAVE LOST THEIR PERSONAL
FAMILY HOMES.
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ARE
DISPLACED AND ARE NOW ATTENDING
NEW AND DIFFERENT SCHOOLS.
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS HAVE LOST INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME.
DO TO SCHOOL CLOSURES RELATED TO
MEET IT RELATED TO THE IMMEDIATE
THREATEN SAFETY AND AIR QUALITY
CONCERNS OF THESE DISASTERS.
THE PANELISTS INVITED TO PROVIDE
TO MY TESTIMONY FOR TODAY'S
HEARING REPRESENT MANY PARTS OF
THE STATE OF THE STATE'S MOST
DIRECTLY OF THE STATE MOST
DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
BY THE DAMAGE.
AND DESTRUCTION OF THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS.
THIS HEARING WILL HELP US
REFLECT UPON ANY LESSONS LEARNED
IN AREAS WHERE STATE POLICY.
COULD IMPROVE CONDITIONS FOR
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES AS THEY
PREPARE FOR AND RESPOND TO AND
RECOVER FROM.
FUTURE NATURAL DISASTERS.
SO THIS IS AN ONLY ABOUT THE
PAST THIS IS ABOUT GOING FORWARD
AS WELL WHICH I KNOW SO MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE WORKING HARD TO
DO TODAY.
ALL I WILL LAST FOR A SOME THE
OTHER COMMITTEES MEMBERS WHO ARE
I SEE MISTER MCCARTY HERE SMITH
TO COLLEGE MOMENTARILY --
BUT I DO JUST WANT TO QUIT
COMMON I WANT TO INTRODUCE OUR
JOCELYN TWYLA.
RIGHT THERE ON THE AND THERE SHE
IS A NEW COMMITTEE SECRETARY SO
GIVE HER AWAY SHE DOES A GREAT
JOB SHE'S EXPERIENCE SHE'S
CAPABLE.
AND SHE'S NOW PART OF OUR TEAM
AND WORRY HAD VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
HER WITH US.
AND MARGUERITE REESE TO MY RIGHT
WHO BRINGS GREAT EXPERIENCE --
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND ACTUALLY
WORK EDUCATION ON HELPING THE
SCHOOLS AS THEY WENT THROUGH
SOME OF THE RECENT DISASTER SO
SHE BRINGS GREAT EXPERIENCE AND
REALLY LED THE EFFORT TO PUT.
TODAY'S HEARING TOGETHER SO SO
WELCOME BOTH OF YOU AND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU --
IN WITH THAT --
WE JUST SAY A FEW WORDS I DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL
UP TO PARADISE --
IT WAS --
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE TO
SEE THAT FIRST HAND YOU SEE IT
ON TV IT'S ONE THING YOU SEE IT
IN PERSON IT'S QUITE ANOTHER
THING IT WAS VERY IMPACTFUL --
WE HAD THE CHANCE SOME OF ITS
SIMILAR GALLAGHER LET LET THE
TRIP UP THERE.
I HAD THE CHANCE TO MEET WITH
MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS IS A
HOURS CITY MANAGERS --
SUPERINTENDENTS WHERE THERE. TO
TO EDUCATE US AS TO THE IMPACT
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES NOW.
AND JUST THE VISUALS THERE WHILE
YOU KNOW YOU SEE A PICTURE THAT
YOU SEE IN REAL LIFE IT IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY BY AND
LARGE IT IS GONE AND NOW IT IS
OUR JOB AS A STATE TO HELP
REBUILD THAT COMMUNITY HELP OUR
FAMILIES OUR STUDENTS.
FIND A NEW NORMAL THAT IS OUR
JOB IT IS TO LISTEN.
AND THEN ACT HOW CAN WE AS A
STATE HELP THESE COMMUNITIES
FIND THEIR NEW NORMAL.
HELP THEIR HELP OUR STUDENTS
FIND THEIR NEW NORMAL --
SO WITH THAT I KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARTY WHICH IS TO SAY A
FEW WORDS MISTER MCCARTY.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT HEARING TO BECAUSE AS
WE TALK ABOUT WILDFIRES IS.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT THEIR
IS THE PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IMPACTS --
BUT ITS IMPACT ON OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND OUR KIDS ARE I THINK
AN IMPORTANT WANT TO LOOK INTO --
THERE CERTAINLY THE IMMEDIATE
THINGS WHICH WHICH I'M GOING TO
HAVE -- SOME
QUESTIONS ON BUT WE DO WITH THE
KIDS WITH NO CLASSROOMS AND
EIGHTY A AND GETTING KANSEN
ROLLED AND ALL THAT LOGISTICS
ISSUES BUT I SUPPOSE SAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
YOU KNOW WE HAD --
YOU KNOW.
WE CERTAINLY SAW THE SMOKE WE
HAVE THE IMPACT NOW I HAVE SOME
PEOPLE MY DISTRICT TO OUR HAVE
RELOCATED.
IN THE CLEANING ONE FAMILY WITH
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR KIDS.
BUT THE ONE ISSUE THAT I WANT TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION ASK OUR
SCHOOL OFFICIALS FROM CD AND
ALSO OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS SOMETIMES BELIEVE IT OR
NOT THE SMOKE WAS WORSE HERE
THAN IT WAS CLOSER.
UP THERE IN PARADISE IN CHICO
AND THE AREAS TO THERE WAS NO
STANDARD FOR WHAT TO DO WITH OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS --
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE HAVE
ABOUT MY JUST WAS ABOUT SEVEN
MIGHT SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DISTRICTS IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS.
THEY ALL HAD HAD DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES THERE WAS NOT KIND OF
A UNIFORM.
WELL SEE THERE IS QUESTIONS IS
IT THERE THEY AIR QUALITY
OFFICERS DECISION IS A LOCAL
SUPERINTENDENTS ISN'T BECAUSE AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
SO.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME --
DEEP THOUGHT ABOUT THIS AND SOME
CLARIFICATION LOOKING IN A
POTENTIAL LEGISLATION IN --
TEN TWENTY NINETEEN BUT THAT'S
ONE ISSUE I WANT TO LOOK INTO
TODAY THANKS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT MISS SMITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON I JUST WANT TO
EXTEND A WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU
ANA STAKES FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND PULLING THIS
TOGETHER --
AS CHAIR O'DONNELL MENTIONED
THERE ARE AND MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER MCCARTY NO SHORTAGE OF
ISSUES THAT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS SO YOUR FIRST PERSON
ACCOUNTS --
INFORM THIS PROCESS IN A VERY
VERY MEANINGFUL WAY I PERSONALLY
HAVE JUST COME OFF NINE YEARS OF
SERVICE ON A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
IN SANTA CLARITA WHERE ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS FOR NATURAL
DISASTER PURPOSES WE DID HAVE TO
EVACUATE SCHOOLS.
BUT NOTHING COMPARED TO WHAT --
EACH OF YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE SO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN DO. TO BE
HELPFUL IN YOUR RECOVERY PROCESS
AND GETTING THE KIDS BACK INTO
AN APPROPRIATE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE ANXIOUS TO DO SO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU.
A THANK YOU --
MISTER GALLAGHER AND I JUST WANT
TO GET IN --
I I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE --
THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
ISSUE THAT'S FOR IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU WERE --
INSTRUMENTAL PUTTING TOGETHER A
GROUP OF LEGISLATORS AND THEY
GAVE US A TOUR OF THE IMPACT
AREAS A BIT MORE POORLY MATHIS
HAS ME THE PEOPLE.
FROM THE IMPACTED AREAS AND I
WAS VERY EDUCATIONAL TO ME.
WHY IT'S IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
NATURAL DISASTERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY HAPPENED?
WHAT IS THE NATURAL DISASTERS
THAT HAVE YET TO OCCUR THAT'S
ONE OF THE OTHER REASONS WE'RE
HERE TODAY SO MISTER GALLAGHER?
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I I I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
COMING UP ON THAT TOUR AND YOU
KNOW -- AS
YOU ALLUDED TO THEM IS VERY EYE
OPENING WHEN YOU SEE THE
DEVASTATION UP THERE --
AND I THINK THAT THIS THIS
COMMITTEE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING
ON THIS COMMITTEE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING --
SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FIRST HAND --
FROM THE EDUCATORS --
ON SOME OF THE MANY DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE MAYBE JUST
DON'T THINK ABOUT --
IN THE AFTERMATH OF OF DISASTERS
AND IF WE OFTENTIMES I WAS JUST
MEETING WITH SOME TEACHERS
ACTUALLY.
FROM THE PARADISE AREA AND SOME
ARE HERE TODAY --
ABOUT --
OFTENTIMES WE THINK ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW THE THE BRICKS AND
MORTAR THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO
TO REBUILD A COMMUNITY TO
RECOVER FROM A DISASTER.
AND WE MAYBE DON'T OFTEN THINK
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THINGS IN THE
AND AND EDUCATION AS PART OF
THAT BY LIVE FOR STRUCTURE --
AND THIS IS CERTAINLY --
A COMMUNITY THAT.
IS VERY IS RESILIENT.
I'M IS WANTING.
TO GET BACK AND RECOVER ON THE
RIDGE AND AND BUT THERE'S WE
NEED SOME --
STABILITY TO ENSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS.
GOING FORWARD AND I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR SOME THINGS ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
THE THE PEOPLE OR A EXPERIENCE
BOTH TEACHERS AND STUDENTS.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS REALLY I
THINK GIVES OUT FULL VIEW AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN YOU PUT
IN THE FOCUS ON ON THIS.
ON THIS ISSUE SO --
GLENDALE GAUGE ON THIS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
GREAT THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
NOT JUST ABOUT REBUILDING
BUILDING REBUILDING BUILDINGS.
BUT IT'S ABOUT REBUILDING LIVES
AND SUPPORTING A LOT OF NEEDS TO
COME WITH A VERY.
TRAGIC EVENT LIKE THAT.
LIKE THIS IS SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER TO PANEL NUMBER.
ONE AND THAT AS EXPERIENCES OF
SCHOOL LEADERS AND ALL INTRODUCE
OURSELVES FIRST SPEAKER --
SO MAYBE THAT THE ENTIRE FIRST
PANEL OUR FIRST SPEAKER IS --
MICHELLE JOHN AS SUPERINTENDENT
OF PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN BUTTE COUNTY.
AND WE ALSO HAVE --
DAVID SMITH HE'S A SECONDARY
TEACHER AT RID YOU CONTINUATION
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEN WILL HAVE --
AMY HOUSING A SUPERINTENDENT
PRINCIPLE FROM COLD SPRING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY REMEMBER
FOCUSES ON NATURAL DISASTERS
TODAY.
THOSE THAT OCCURRED THOSE THAT
HAVE YET TO OCCUR.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT FIRE
THEIR OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS.
THAT HAVE HAPPENED WILL HAPPEN
ACROSS OUR STATE SO THAT OUR
FIRST SPEAKER.
IS -- WE
HAVE A FOUR SPEAKER I'M SORRY
IT'S AS THOUGH WE MILLER A
TEACHER. FOR THE MINOR HIGH
SCHOOL ST IN THE SANTA ROSA CITY
SCHOOLS IN CINEMA COUNTY.
SO WITH THAT OUR FIRST SPEAKER
IS --
MICHELLE JOHN AGAIN.
THE SAME THANK YOU CHAIR
O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE JOHN AND I'M
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PARADISE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ON THE EVENING OF NOVEMBER SIXTH.
DISTRICT PERSONNEL WERE
CELEBRATING THE PASSAGE OF A
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR BOND.
APPROVED.
BY OUR VOTERS.
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD NOT BEEN
ABLE TO PASS A BOND FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS.
OUR STUDENTS WERE FINALLY GOING
TO GET WHAT THEY NEEDED AND
DESERVED.
LESS THAN THIRTY SIX HOURS LATER
IRON TIRE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
STUDENTS STAFF AND FAMILIES WERE
LITERALLY RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES AS A FIRESTORM RAIN DOWN
UPON OUR TOWN.
WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS THE
CAMPFIRE VERY QUICKLY BECAME ONE
LARGE HORRIFIC INFERNO?
DESTROYING EVERYTHING IN ITS
PATH AT THE SPEED OF A FOOTBALL
FIELD LENGTH.
A SECOND.
COMMUNICATION WAS OFF
[inaudible]
WITHIN MINUTES.
AND FOR SURE IN FOUR SHORT HOURS
THERE WERE TREMENDOUS ACTS OF
SELFLESS COURAGE AND DEDICATION.
AS OUR STAFF MOBILIZED EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLANS THAT VERY QUICKLY
ESCALATED INTO A MAD DASH TO GET
PEOPLE TO SAFETY.
WE WERE STARTING TO METHODICALLY
EVACUATE BUT IN LESS THAN AN
HOUR IT BECAME A LIFE AND DEATH
SCENARIO.
DR INTO FLAMES AN ASH CLOUDS
EDUCATORS AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WERE THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
RISKING THEIR OWN LIVES.
AS THEIR OWN HOMES WERE BEING
DESTROYED.
BUSES DROVE TO FLAMES WHILE
SCHOOL STAFF OR TERRAIN AND
WEDDING OFF TEE SHIRTS.
AND PLACING THEM OVER STUDENTS
MOUTHS TO HELP THEM BREATHE TO
THE TOXIC SMOKE.
GATHERING THROUGHOUT THE DAY AT
THE CHICO FAIRGROUNDS IN LATER
PAST MIDNIGHT AT A LARGE CHURCH
AND SHE GO.
WE CAN PROUDLY SAY THAT ALL
THREE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINE STUDENTS AND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY STAFF MEMBERS.
WERE SAFE AND ACCOUNTED.
FOR ON THE MORNING OF NOVEMBER
ELEVENTH I DROVE TO OUR BELOVED
TOWN WITH THE PARADISE FIRE
CHIEF IN THE TOWN MANAGER.
WE DROVE IN STUNNED SILENCE
AROUND DOWNED ELECTRICAL LINES.
FALLING TREES THAT WERE STILL
BURNING AND SMOLDERING.
BUSINESSES AND HOMES DESTROYED.
93% OF OUR TOWN HAD BEEN
DESTROYED.
OUR TOWN MANAGER.
TURNED TO ME WITH TEARS AND SAID.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
WE PREPARED AND PRACTICED.
I HAD NO WORDS TO RESPOND.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO NOTE IS THAT
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE ALL SEEN
PICTURES AND CONTINUE?
TO THE DEVASTATION IS ACTUALLY
MUCH WORSE THAN ANY PICTURE CAN
PORTRAY.
PRIOR TO NOVEMBER EIGHTH GRADE
SCHOOL DISTRICT INCLUDED NINE
CAMPUSES.
OVER FOUR HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND
A BUSTLING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
FOOD SERVICES MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS AND TRANSPORTATION.
WE WERE THE SECOND LARGEST
EMPLOYER ON THE RIDGE.
WE OVER SOFT FOR SUCCESSFUL
CHARTER SCHOOLS OPERATING WITHIN
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
IN A ROW MET A THREE THOUSAND
BORDER NINE STUDENTS WE ALSO HAD
THE HIGHEST ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
SCORES IN THE STATE.
AND QUALIFIED 41100% FREE OR
REDUCED LUNCH.
WE HAD OUR HANDS FULL.
WE ARE PROUD OF OUR OF OUR
LATEST CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD RESULTS ARE A PEACE
CORPS STUDENTS SCORED ABOVE
STATE.
NATION A GLOBAL RESULTS AND OUR
SPORTS TEAMS WERE QUALIFIED FOR
PLAYOFFS IN EVERY SPORT.
FRIDAY NIGHT'S MUCH OF THE TOWN
COULD BE FOUND AT OUR FOOTBALL
GAMES.
WE WERE WORKING HARD AND FLYING
HIGH.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY. NINETY
ONE DAYS LATER.
WE ARE CURRENTLY A DISTRICT OF
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE STUDENTS.
THAT'S 852% OF OUR FORMER
STUDENT POPULATION.
WE HAVE CAMPUS IS LOCATED A MALL
STORE FRONTS.
TEACHERS TEACHING IN HARDWARE
STORE AISLES AMONG THE SHELL
BEING AT AN OLD OFSHE BUILDING.
AN OFFICE BUILDING BY THE CHICO
AIRPORT.
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB CENTER.
A BORROWED REDDIT SCHOOL FROM A
NEIGHBORING JUST YOUR AND WE ARE
SHARING A CAMPUS WITH A
DIFFERENT NEIGHBORING DISTRICT.
ALL OF OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE
FOUND PLACES IN HURCHES AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS.
SOME STATISTICS 93% OF OUR
STUDENTS LOST OR WERE DISPLACED
FROM THEIR HOMES. TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY P. U. S. D. STAFF
MEMBERS.
HOMES WERE ALSO DESTROYED AND
ANOTHER SIXTY HAVE HOMES THAT
WERE DAMAGED THAT THEY CANNOT
RETURN. TO THREE OF OUR FOUR TO
FIVE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS LOST
THEIR HOMES. FOUR OF OUR NINE
CAMPUSES WERE DESTROYED AND
ANOTHER FOR DAMAGE SEVERELY.
1100% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE NOW
CONSIDERED HOMELESS AND QUALIFY
FOR EXTRA SUPPORT.
UNDER THE MCKINNEY VENTO PROGRAM.
THE THIS DISASTER HAS CHANGED
THE TRAJECTORY OF MY LIFE.
AND THE LIVES OF OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES.
LAST WEEK I WAS TOLD BY OUR TOWN
MANAGER THAT THERE WAS NOT ONE
SINGLE PROPERTY PARADISE.
THAT DID NOT HAVE SOME SORT OF
BURN ON IT.
WE HAVE BEEN OVERWHELMED AND
HUMBLED BY THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
AND LOVE WE RECEIVE FROM ARE
FELLOW EDUCATORS FROM ALL OVER
OUR COUNTRY.
IT IS OUR GREAT DESIRE TO IT
SOME TIME PAID THIS KIND IS FOR
TO OTHERS WHO MAY FIND HIMSELF
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS.
SO WHAT DO WE NEED FROM YOU.
WE NEED LONG TERM FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO HELP OUR DISTRICTS
SURVIVE REDUCTION IN STUDENTS
WALK FAMILIES REBUILD AND RETURN
TO PARADISE.
WE NEED QUALIFIED GRIEF
COUNSELORS.
THAT ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY.
AND WE ARE AND ABLE TO FIND ANY
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MORE THAN
OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF ALREADY
PROVIDED. TO ADDRESS BOTH
STUDENT AND STAFF SUBSTANTIAL
LONG TERM MENTAL HEALTH AND
EMOTIONAL NEEDS.
AS WE DEAL WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TRAUMA.
WE NEED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
HIRE QUALIFIED EXPERTS TO HELP
US NAVIGATE THE INTRICACIES AND
MANDATES OF FEMA CALLOW YES CAL
FIRE CD E..
AND OTHER STATE RESPOND HERS.
OUR STAFF ARE TRAINED EDUCATORS
AND WE SIR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
THIS IS BE ON OUR SCOPE A
TRAINING AND PRACTICE.
THE DISTRICT HAS INCURRED AND
WILL CONTINUE TO OCCUR
SIGNIFICANT FEES AS WE COMPLY
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
AS WE RESPOND AND RECOVER FROM
THIS DISASTER.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED?
WE HAVE LEARNED UNDER STRESSFUL
CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT BEING
FLEXIBLE [inaudible]
PERSEVERING.
PRACTICING PATIENCE.
ACCEPTING HELP FROM OUR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
MY FELLOW STUDENTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE NATION.
BUSINESSES ATHLETES OTHER
COUNTRIES STRANGERS.
AND EVEN SMALL CHILDREN HANDING
US THEIR ALLOWANCES.
WE HAVE LEARNED TO SAY YES
PLEASE AND THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LEARNED TO LOVE EACH
OTHER EVEN WHEN WE ARE TIRED AND
A LITTLE ANGRY.
AND HOW IT IS OKAY TO CRY AND
LEAN ON EACH OTHER.
BECAUSE IN THIS TRAGEDY WE ARE
ALL VICTIMS HELPING VICTIMS.
THIS SPRING SB ON IT IS OUR GOAL
TO CONTINUE TO EDUCATE UST
STUDENTS.
AND TAKE CARE OF OUR STAFF.
WE ARE IN THE BEGINNING STAGES
THE CAMPAIGN WE HAVE TITLED WERE
COMING HOME.
P. U. S. D. IS A STRONG DISTRICT
AND COMMUNITY.
IT WILL TAKE MANY YEARS AND A
GREAT DEAL OF HELP AND FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. TO REBUILD OUR TOWN
IN SCHOOLS.
BUT NEVER DOUBT.
THE LITTLE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE
WILL DO JUST THAT.
WE ARE NOW HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE RICH
STRONG.
OUR STUDENTS NEED AND DESERVE
THIS.
CLEESE BE PART OF THE HELP THAT
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHN WILL NOW
HEAR FROM A TEACHER FROM THE
SCENE OF YOU PARRIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT DAVID SMITH
[inaudible]
MISTER SMITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DESCRIBE MY
EXPERIENCE THE CAMPFIRE.
NAME IS DAVID SMITH I'M A MATH
TEACHER AT THE CONTINUATION
SCHOOL RIDGEVIEW HIGH SCHOOL IN
PARADISE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AS WELL AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OF PARADISE.
HERE A FEW PICTURES OF MY
CLASSROOM WHERE I TAUGHT MATH
FOUNDATIONS FINANCIAL LITERACY
AND INTEGRATED MATH.
REGGIE WITH THE RESCUE RANGERS A
CLASS THAT DOES A LOT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE ACTIVITIES
THROUGHOUT BUTTE COUNTY.
THAT ALL CHANGED ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTH.
WHEN I GOT TO RICH VIEW SPOT
FIRE STARTED COMING OVER THE
RIDGE FROM CON CAL?
MY PRINCIPAL WAS ALREADY SENDING
PARENTS WAY WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
MY PRINCIPAL AND I CENTER CO
WORKERS HOME TO BE BACK WITH
THEIR FAMILIES MAKE SURE ALL OUR
STUDENTS WERE EVACUATED AND WERE
THE LAST ONES TO LEVERAGE AT
NINE O'CLOCK.
THE THIRTY FIVE MINUTE DRIVE TO
ORVILLE TURN INTO A FIVE AND A
HALF HOUR HORRIFYING TRAFFIC JAM
FILLED FLEE.
FROM WHAT FELT LIKE AN ERUPTING
VOLCANO.
TWICE SO STUCK IN TRAFFIC SO
CLOSE TO THE FIRE SORRY.
THAT I THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE TO
ABANDON MY TRUCK.
DURING THE WHOLE EVACUATION MY
ADRENALINE WAS RACING AND ALL I
COULD THINK ABOUT.
WAS TO GET HOME TO MY FAMILY IN
CHICO WE'RE RIGHT WHERE IT WAS
SAFE.
I CAN IMAGINE WITH THOSE WHO ARE
FLEEING FROM THEIR HOMES WITH
THINKING.
ONCE OFF THE HILL.
ARE UNION MEMBERS STARTED
CALLING TO MAKE SURE TEACHERS
WERE SAFE.
AT THE SAME TIME TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS CALLED FAMILIES
TO REUNITE THEM WITH THEIR
STUDENTS.
AND MAKE SURE ALL OUR STUDENTS
WERE COUNTED.
FOR AS YOU KNOW BY THE GRACE OF
GOD.
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF
WERE SAFELY EVACUATED.
MOST MEMBERS FOR THE RELATIVES
OR FRIENDS WHO COULD TAKE THEM
AND SOME TEACHERS.
LANDED AS FAR AWAY AS WASHINGTON
OREGON NEVADA AND EVEN KANSAS.
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBERS WHO LIVED OR
WORKED IN THE FIRE BRIMSTONE
HAVE ENTERED AN APPLICATION FOR
CTA DISASTER RELIEF GRANTS.
ACCORDING TO OUR TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SURVEY A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN OF FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TWO
TEACHERS WERE DISPLACED. SEVENTY
SEVEN OF THOSE LOST THEIR HOMES.
SINCE THE FIRE OF GATHERED AND
DISTRIBUTED DONATIONS AND
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO ANSWER
MY MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
ALONG WITH PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
REASSURANCE TO MY FELLOW
COWORKERS.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE HAS BEEN
FINDING HOUSING FOR THOSE WHO
WERE DISPLACED.
MANY TEACHERS ARE LIVING IN
TRAILERS ARE SHARING HOMES WITH
FRIENDS OR FAMILY WHILE WAITING
TO REBUILD.
HOUSING IS STILL DIFFICULT TO
FIND A FEW COUNTY NOT ONLY
AFFECTING THOSE DISPLACED BUT
ALSO ANY BUSINESSES TRYING TO
HIRE NEW EMPLOYEES.
MY DISTRICT ADMINISTRATORS.
HAVE IN AN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
JOB TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REBUILD A SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM
ALMOST NOTHING.
INCLUDING SEARCHING FOR LARGE
ENOUGH FACILITIES FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF.
THE NO FAULT OF OUR DISTRICT
COMMUNICATION WAS LIMITED DUE TO
SO MANY UNKNOWNS.
SO I TOOK IT UPON MYSELF AS
PRESIDENT TO BE THE LIAISON
BETWEEN THE DISTRICT OFFICE AND
MY TEACHERS.
IN THIS TIME OF CRISIS PEOPLE
WERE FILLED WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE.
AND THE BIGGEST CAUSE OF ANXIETY
IS WHETHER PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
STILL HAVE THEIR JOBS.
WITHOUT A CLEAR BUDGET IN PLACE.
OUR DISTRICT WAS INITIALLY
HESITANT TO STATE THE JOBS OR
SAFETY ON NOVEMBER.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
UNINTENTIONALLY CAUSED UNDUE
STRESS AND TREPIDATION.
RECENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
WORKED WITH OUR ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT BUSINESS SERVICES
ON P. WESTIES BUDGET FOR THIS
YEAR AND NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S IT APPEARS WE CAN AVOID
MASSIVE LAYOFFS SO SOON AFTER
THE DISASTER.
HOWEVER BEYOND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY THE BUDGET IS
STILL UNKNOWN AND FILLS MY
TEACHERS WITH DREAD WONDERING IF
OR WHEN THEY'LL HAVE TO SEARCH
FOR NEW JOBS AND LEAVE PARADISE.
I BELIEVE HAVING DISASTER PLAN
THAT INCLUDED PRE FIRE EIGHTY A
FUNDING FOR MULTIPLE YEARS
DEPENDING ON THE ENORMITY OF THE
DISASTER.
AND PORTABLE CLASSROOMS FOR
SCHOOLS THAT WERE DESTROYED
WOULD BE EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL
FOR ADMINISTRATORS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHEN FACED WITH THE
DISASTER SUCH AS THE CAMPFIRE.
THE IMPACT OF POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER ON FIRE VICTIMS
HAS BEEN CLEARLY EVIDENT.
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFICULTY SLEEPING
OR NIGHTMARES ABOUT THE FIRE.
HIGHER BRAIN MAKES CONCENTRATING
OR MAKING DECISIONS VERY
CHALLENGING.
DO THE UNCONVENTIONAL CLASSROOMS
HIGH VOLUME LEVELS OF BECAUSE
STUDENT OUTBURSTS.
AND TEACHERS NEED TO TAKE MENTAL
BREAKS.
STAFFER EMOTIONALLY DRAINED AND
DON'T HAVE THE ENERGY AFTER
SCHOOL TO MAKE PHONE CALLS TO
TRY TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK
TOGETHER.
DRIVING TO THE DEVASTATION TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO STUDENTS IN
THE GALLEY IN DECEMBER.
BECAUSE TWO OF OUR TEACHERS TO
RESIGN AND TWO OTHERS TO GO OUT
ON DISABILITY LEAVE.
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
FIRE IN THE TIME.
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT AND
POSITIVE ENCOURAGEMENT IN ORDER
TO RECOVER.
I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA.
AND LAST JULY MY LONG TIME
FRIEND WHO NOW LIVES IN LAKE
COUNTY CAME TO STAY WITH ME
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN BACK WHEN
FOR THE MEDICINE A COMPLEX FIRE.
HE COULDN'T GO BACK TO READING
BECAUSE HIS PARENTS WERE
DISPLACED TO THE CAR FIRE IT'S
TIME.
EVERY MORNING AND EVENING WE
WOULD WATCH THE TELEVISION
COVERAGE WAITING TO HEAR
ENCOURAGING NEWS BOTH FIRES.
AND I REMEMBER THINKING HOW SAD
I WAS WATCHING THE CITY I GREW
UP IN. FOR MANY OF MY FRIENDS TO
LIVE.
GOING UP IN FLAMES.
BUT THAT SADNESS WAS FLEETING.
AND I WOULDN'T THINK ABOUT IT
WELL I WENT ABOUT MY DAY
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
AFTER EXPERIENCING THE CAMPFIRE.
I TRULY UNDERSTAND THE DRAMATIC
IMPACT OF THIS ACT LIKE THIS HAS
ON PEOPLE.
THERE IS NO FORGETTING ABOUT IT
DURING THE DAY.
I THINK ABOUT THE FIRE
[inaudible]
SORRY.
OR ITS IMPACT OF MY COMMUNITY
CONSTANTLY.
AND IT'S HARD TO SHUT OFF.
THIS CATASTROPHE IS TURN
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S LIVES
UPSIDE DOWN.
AND I FIND THE COURAGE.
AND RESILIENCE OF OUR STUDENTS
PARENTS SCHOOL STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS.
TRULY AMAZING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HOPE THIS TESTIMONY HOPES IN
SHAPING POLICY THAT WILL BENEFIT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE RECOVERY
FROM FUTURE DISASTERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SMITH THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS ANY ALCINA
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLE FROM
COLD SPRING ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
GOOD FTERNOON I AM EMAILS IN OF
THE SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLE OF
THE COLD SPRING SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND MINUS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
IT'S AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO
BE HERE SO THANK YOU.
THE COLD SPRING SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS A SINGLE ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BASIC AID.
WE HAVE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH SIXTH GRADE
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT STUDENTS.
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT KASPARS
CULTURING SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
RANKED AMONGST YOUR TOP SCHOOL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
92% OF YOUR STUDENTS MEDIAN
EXCEEDING THE STANDARDS IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS.
AND 90% OF YOUR STUDENTS AND
MATHEMATICS.
ON JANUARY EIGHTH.
I RECALL IT BEING A VERY
BEAUTIFUL SUNNY DAY AND SECOND
GUESSING MY DECISION TO CANCEL
SCHOOL.
BECAUSE I'D CANCEL SCHOOL SO
MANY TIMES FOR THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER DUE TO THE THOMAS FIRE.
HI THEY MADE A WRONG DECISION
WITH THESE PARENTS FROM THIS
HIGH PERFORMING DISTRICTS
CERTAINLY CRUCIFY A FRESHMAN
SUPERINTENDENT.
BUT LO AND BEHOLD.
THE NEXT MORNING AT THREE THIRTY
IN THE MORNING THE RAINS CAME
DOWN.
I LOOKED OUTSIDE MY WINDOW MY
MINUS YOU DON'T HOME. TO SEE THE
LIGHT THE SKY LIT UP.
OR INJURED THAN I'D EVER SEEN.
I WAS CONFUSED HOW CAN THIS GUY
BE RAD.
AND AT THE SAME TIME HAVE RAIN
COMING DOWN AS HARD AS IT AS IT
AS I WENT TO FIND MY CELL PHONE.
DAVID HI HAD NO SELF POWER.
AND AT THAT TIME A MEMBER AGAIN
BEING CONFUSED WAS UNTIL FIVE
THIRTY IN THAT NEXT MORNING WARY
LEARNED THAT. THIRTY SQUARE
MILES AND MINUS YOU KNOW HAD
BEEN COVERED WITH MAD DEBRIS AND
BOULDERS WHITE BEAN OUT HOMES.
TAKING FAMILIES ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE OCEAN FROM THEIR HOMES.
AND DESTROYING MANY TRAPPED
UNDERNEATH THE DEBRIS.
WITH MY CELL PHONE IN HAND I
MANAGED TO FIND MY WAY AUTUMN
HONESTY DOWN.
AND CONTACT EACH ONE OF MY STAFF
MEMBERS.
AND TOGETHER WE CONTACTED ALL OF
OUR PARENTS. TO DEFINE THAT MANY
OF OUR CHILDREN WERE DAD.
JANUARY NINTH WAS EXTREMELY HARD
DAY AS A SUPERINTENDENT AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE CONTACTING.
WITH THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OUR NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS WE CERTAINLY COULD
HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT THEM AND AS
WELL AS OUR GOVERNANCE BOARD.
THE MINUS YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
LAST TWENTY THREE PEOPLE TO ARE
STILL MISSING TO THIS DAY.
OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE
WERE CRITICALLY INJURED. NINE
HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE RESCUED
WITHIN THE FIRST TWELVE HOURS OF
THE DEBRIS FLOW. FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN HOMES WERE
DESTROYED AND DAMAGED AND THE
ONE OH ONE FREEWAY WAS CLOSED
FOR TWO WEEKS.
DISRUPTING THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
A SINGLE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
OFTEN ELOQUENT. TO HANDLE A
NATURAL DISASTER LIKE THIS I AM
THE SOLE ADMINISTRATOR.
AGAIN IF IT WASN'T FOR THE HELP
OF OUR NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS WE
WOULD NOT OF GOD DO THIS.
IN THESE EMERGENCIES DISTRICTS
NEED SUPPORT IN THE FORM OF
TRAUMA COUNSELING FOR STUDENTS
AND STAFF.
IMMEDIATE ACCESS FOR FUNDING
WHICH INCLUDES THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL EDUCATION
SERVICES OUTSIDE THE REGULAR
SCHOOL DAY.
AND FLEXIBILITY IS OR EXEMPTIONS
FROM CURRENT STATE LAW.
FORTUNATELY THE CUT COLD SPRING
CAMPUS SEVERED MINOR PHYSICAL
DAMAGES THAT A NOTIONAL TRAUMA
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THE WELLNESS SUPPORT WAS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE RESTART OF
SCHOOL AS WE INSURED EVERY
TEACHER WAS EQUIPPED WITH A
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST OR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL TO SUPPORT
NOT ONLY THE TEACHER BUT THE
STUDENTS.
THESE CONTINUE SERVICES REQUIRE
FINDING.
AS DO THE SUPPLE AT A
SUPPLEMENTAL EDUCATION SERVICES
AND IMMEDIATE FUNDING.
DURING THE THOMAS FIRE MUD
SLIDES.
STUDENTS LOTS THE TOTAL TWELVE
DAYS OF INSTRUCTION WHICH IS 10%
ALMOST NEARLY 10% OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR AND ADDITION WE HAD TO
RELOAD OUR CAMPUS SEVERAL TIMES
DURING THE MONTH OF MARCH
BECAUSE OF MANDATORY EVACUATIONS.
SHOULD SHE OF THE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES THAT WE RECEIVED.
WE HAD TO DO.
AND STILL MANY BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL TUTORING FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AGAIN THIS COST FUNDING REQUIRES
FINDING.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT A STORY
ABOUT A KINDERGARTEN STUDENT WAS
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER AT
COLD SPRING SCHOOL WHOSE MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER WERE WORKING THE
NIGHT SHIFT AT THE BOND
SUPERMARKET ON THE NIGHT OF
JANUARY NINTH.
AFTER THE MUD SLIDES THEY
REALIZE THEY COULD NOT GET TO
THEIR HOMES SO THEY SOMEHOW
MANAGED TO FIND THEIR WAY TO THE
MOTEL.
SIX WHERE THE NEXT MORNING THEY
WERE GREETED BY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THAT INFORMED THEM
THAT THEIR SIGN A KINDERGARTEN
STUDENT.
HAD BEEN KILLED AND THAT HIS
BODY WAS TAKEN ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE RAILROAD TRACKS.
HIS FATHER WAS KILLED AND HIS
GRAN.
THIS FAMILY WAS OUR HER OUTLOOK
FAMILY AND OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
IT'S THEY STILL LEAVE A WHOLE.
THE PAST OF THE STORY OF PASTA
REPRESENTS THE CHIU NATURE WHAT
A DISASTER LIKE THIS MEANS TO
THE COMMUNITY.
OUR RECOVERY EFFORTS ARE ONGOING.
OUR COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE THE AFTER EFFECTS OF
THE THOMAS A BUYER WITH REPEATED
EVACUATIONS THAT EVEN JUST
OCCURRED THIS LAST WEEKEND.
NEW DEBRIS FLOWS AND EGGS IT
AFTER EACH RAINSTORM OCCUR.
BUT ON JANUARY NINTH OF THIS
YEAR WE COMMEMORATED THE ONE
YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE DEADLY
DEBRIS FLOW BY HOLDING A
CANDLELIGHT VIGIL AND PER
SESSION TO REMEMBER THE TWENTY
THREE MINUS YOU TO RESIDENTS
THAT WERE KILLED.
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE OF
ALL AGES ATTENDED THE CEREMONY
WERE BOTH PRIVATE.
AND PUBLIC MINUS YOU TO CHILDREN
CAME TOGETHER TO SING THIS
LITTLE LIGHT OF MINE.
BEFORE FALLING EACH HEAD OF
SCHOOL DURING A CANDLELIGHT
PROCESSION REPRESENTING LIVE AND
HOPE FOR OUR FUTURE.
I CAN ONLY HOPE THAT OUR
COLLABORATIVE ACTS AS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS.
ARE TEACHING AND SHOWING OUR
CHILDREN WHAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER
WHEN WE TRULY WORK TOGETHER AND
LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
WHICH IS ONE OF LIFE'S GREATEST
LESSONS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU CELLS IN A NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM SO A MILLER A TEACHER
OF FOR THE PLAYER HIGH SCHOOL IN
SANTA ROSA CITY SCHOOLS IN
CINEMA COUNTY [inaudible]
A SIMILAR.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME --
MY NAME IS TONY MILLER AND I AM
A TEACHER AT PINE A HIGH SCHOOL
CENTER IS A CITY SCHOOLS.
OUR SCHOOL IS LOW SOCIOECONOMIC
PREDOMINANTLY HISPANIC ESL ELT
SECOND LANGUAGE LEARNERS --
WITH APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS AT OUR SCHOOL.
IN OCTOBER THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN MY HOME IN A LOT
FILLED WITH THAT PART OF SANTA
ROSA BURNED DOWN THE TOUGH FIRE
SCHOOLS AND ALSO.
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
ABOUT A HUNDRED OF OUR STUDENTS
AND A HUNDRED OF OUR STAFF
MEMBERS LOST THEIR HOMES AND
EVERYTHING IN THEM.
THIS CALL MAY NEED TWENTY FOUR
MEANING SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED FOR
THREE WEEKS.
EVERY SCHOOL WITH AFFECTED BY
TOXIC ASHEN SMOKE AND YOU'D BE
PROFESSIONALLY CLEANED AND
CERTIFIED AS SAFE.
AT PINE UP FIFTY SIX KIDS LOST
THEIR HOUSES IN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WERE
AFFECTED WERE EITHER EVACUATED
OR STOLE THEIR HOMES DAMAGED.
SIX OF OUR STAFF LOST THEIR
HOMES. ONE OF OUR HIGH SCHOOLS
AND ONE OF OUR MIDDLE SCHOOLS
WERE USED DURING SUCH AS
SHELTERS DURING THE CRISIS.
AS THERE IS WE WOULD IMITATE THE
PINE A STAFF CALLED EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT TO SEE IF THERE ARE
AFFECTED BY THE FIRE THEY MADE A
LIST OF THOSE AFFECTED AND RANK
THEM FROM MOST TO LEAST AFFECTED.
FINANCIAL AID WAS ORGANIZED AND
DISTRIBUTED BY APPOINTMENT TO
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WE RECEIVED
GIFT CARDS AND CHECKS MUCH
THROUGH THE REDWOOD CREDIT UNION
FUND RAISER.
THE PGA BOOSTERS HELD A DONATION
DRIVE AT THE PARK ACROSS THE
STREET FOR FAMILIES WHO NEEDED
BLANKETS TOWELS TOILETRIES
ETCETERA.
BACKPACKS SCHOOL SUPPLIES IN
COMPUTERS WERE HANDED OUT TO
THOSE IN NEED. TWO DAYS PRIOR TO
OUR SCHOOL WE OPENING THE
STUDENTS AND THE STAFF WERE
BROUGHT TOGETHER TO DISCUSS WHAT
THE FIRST FEW DAYS OF PINE A
WOULD BE LIGHT.
WE DECIDED TO SPEND THE DAY ON
FRIDAY OPENING DAY CONNECTING
WITH THE CHILDREN AND REACHING
OUT TO THOSE STUDENTS WHO NEEDED
SUPPORT THE FIRST DAY BACK.
THERE WERE MANY COUNSELORS AND
THERAPISTS AVAILABLE FOR THE
STUDENTS.
WE PROVIDED A QUIET SAFE PLACE
FOR THOSE WHO COULDN'T STAY IN
THE CLASSROOM.
MANY STUDENTS MET WITH COUNTLESS
AND WE GIVEN SUPPORT.
THE TEACHERS CAME TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH WHAT
THEY NEEDED AND WE TRIED OUR
BEST TO MEET THEIR NEEDS.
TOGETHER WITH THE DISTRICT PINE
HIGH SCHOOL MANAGE THE MEDIA SO
WOULD NOT BE OBTRUSIVE TO THE
CHILDREN AND YET BE ABLE TO TELL
A STORY.
IN MY CLASSROOM SEVERAL
REPORTERS AND TELEVISION CAMERAS.
DOCUMENTED OFF FIRST DAY BACK
AND GAVE CRITICAL COMMUNITY
ABOUT SCHOOL OPENINGS AND
RESOURCES SUCH AS COUNSELING AND
FREE MEALS.
THE STUDENTS APPRECIATE THE
GENTLE TRANSITION BACK TO
ACADEMICS BY THE MIDDLE OF THE
WEEK WE RESUMES CURRICULUM AND
THE KIDS WERE PLACED.
AS A SEMESTER CONTINUED OUR
COUNSELORS AND TEACHERS CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT TO THE
STUDENTS.
WE REGULATE CHECKED IN ON THOSE
WOULD LOST THEIR HOUSES AND
STILL FEELING THE EFFECT THE
FIRES.
MANY FIRE AFFECTED STUDENTS
STRUGGLED ACADEMICALLY AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO TODAY.
AS TEACHERS WE REALIZED THAT THE
EFFECTS OF THE FIRE WITH LINGER.
IT TOOK ME UNTIL JANUARY BEFORE
I WAS COMFORTABLE AND
EFFECTIVELY TEACHING AGAIN.
AS A STAFF WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THOSE AFFECTED BY THE
FIRE.
WE CHECKED IN WITH THE CHILDREN
OF THE BEGINNING OF A TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SCHOOL YEAR
AND MANY RESPONDED WITH WE'RE
OKAY WE JUST WANT TO GET THROUGH
THE YEAR.
THE NIGHT OF THE TUBS FIRE THE
OTHER FIRES IS NEVER COUNTY IS
STILL VERY FRESH IN OUR MINDS.
I REMEMBER RUNNING OUT OF A HAT
HOUSE WITH THE CLOTHES ON OUR
BACKS THE DOGS MY WORK COMPUTER.
AND MY STUDENTS ESSAYS IN
NOTEBOOKS I HAD YET TO GREAT
THEY WERE DISAPPOINTED THAT I
STILL HAVE THEM.
WE MANAGE TO REACH A
GIRLFRIEND'S HOUSE OF THEIR
EMAIL MY BOSS.
MADE LESSON PLANS.
ARRANGED FOR SUB THAT MONDAY.
MY FAMILY THEN SAT DOWN TO WATCH
TELEVISION IS A WELL CAUGHT ON
FIRE.
THE LOSS OF COFFEE PARKING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUBDIVISION
WAS DEVASTATING.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS LIVED IN
THAT AREA.
HAS THE SUN REYES ROSE WE
REALIZED HOW MUCH OF OUR CITY
HAD BEEN AFFECTED.
HOW MANY OF OUR FRIENDS AND
STUDENTS LOST THEIR HOUSES?
AS THE STORIES TRICKLED IN WE
WERE HORRIFIED ABOUT THE
DEVASTATION.
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL I WANTED IT
TO BE AS NORMAL AS POSSIBLE SO I
PUT MY MAKE UPON MY HIGH HEELS
AND I DID MY HAIR JUST LIKE
BEFORE.
SO WHEN THE STUDENTS ABOUT IN
THE CLASSROOM I LOOK NORMAL.
WE ARE THE STORIES OF THE
STUDENTS.
HOW MANY EVEN READ OUT OF THEIR
HOUSES AND STORE THEIR HOUSES
BURNING [inaudible]
MANY.
I BACKING AWAY SHE WAS CHAOTIC.
THE MY STUDENTS JAMES IN HIS
TRUCK STRUGGLE TO GET OUT OF
COFFEE PART BECAUSE THE TRAFFIC
WAS SO CONGESTED.
HE REALIZED NO ONE NO ONE WAS
COMING INTO COFFEE PARK.
SO WE DROVE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
THE STREET IN ORDER TO GET OUT
OF HIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
MANY PEOPLE FALLING BEHIND AND
JAMES TOOK A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF PEOPLE OUT OF COFFEE PARK.
ANOTHER ONE OF MY STUDENTS SONYA
LEFT WITH NOTHING BUT HER SCHOOL
BAG AND PAJAMAS.
JANET UP LIVING IN A GARAGE IN A
HOUSE WITH NINE OTHER PEOPLE.
OTHER STUDENTS HAVE LOST TWO
HOUSES BECAUSE THAT DIVORCED
PARENTS EACH LOST HOUSES.
NEED ANOTHER OF MY STUDENTS HAS
TO COMMUTE FROM LAKE COUNTY.
LEVINE A HIGH SCHOOL AN HOUR AND
A HALF DRIVE.
SOMETIMES ON YOU KNOW VERY
SLIPPERY ROADS DURING THE WINTER.
SOME PARENTS OF DIVORCE BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT FACE REBUILDING
TOGETHER. SIXTEEN MONTHS LATER
SOME OF OUR STUDENTS ARE STILL
STRUGGLING.
WITH REBUILDING TAKING SO LONG
OUR STUDENTS ARE FORCED TO
RELOCATE AS THE PROJECTED DATE
OF THEIR REBUILT HOUSE IS PUSHED
FURTHER OUT.
MANY FAMILIES ARE FACED WITH
HAVING TO PAY THEIR MORTGAGE AND
THEIR READ AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS IS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
REBUILDING PERIOD.
I MISS OUR OLD POSSESSIONS AND
LIKE MANY PEOPLE ARE FAMILY DID
NOT HAVE ENOUGH INSURANCE.
IT WAS VERY STRANGE RETURNING TO
PINE A AS MY ONLY SURVIVING
POSSESSIONS WERE IN MY CLASSROOM
PLAN THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COULD FORCE MORE STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS TO LEAVE.
FAMILIES ARE STILL STRUGGLING
MENTALLY AND FINANCIALLY WE ALSO
LOST A MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR
DUE TO BUDGET CUTS.
WHICH WOULD YOU SEE AS OUR
EFFECTIVENESS.
WE ARE STILL STRUGGLING WITH
THIS TODAY AND THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS NOT MAKING IT ANY
EASIER.
WATCHING THE CAR IN THE CAMP
FIRES OVER THE LAST YEAR WAS
LIKE WATCHING CINEMA COUNTY BURN
AGAIN. TO KNOW THAT MANY SO MANY
MORE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LOST
ALL THEY HAD WAS DEVASTATING NOT
KNOWING HOW MUCH IF ANY HELP IS
COMING FROM THE STATE OR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP FAMILIES.
AND ALL SCHOOL ONLY ADDS TO THE
STRESS.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ARE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND SO WHAT THE
CHILDREN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MILLER THANK YOU
TO HALL PALACE --
IT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HERE --
AND ASK OF THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ANY OF THE THE
PRESENTERS HERE TODAY.
AND JUST BE MINDFUL THAT WE DO
HAVE OTHERS THAT ARE GOING TO
PRESENT AS WELL MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU OFFER YOUR HEARTFELT
TESTIMONY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT --
ALL OF YOU MENTIONED IN SOME
RESPECTS --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR BOTH
YOUR STUDENTS AND YOUR STAFF IF
EACH OF YOU COULD SPEAK BRIEFLY
TO THE AMOUNT OF COUNSELING IF
ANY PER ADA PER STAFF MEMBER
THAT HAS BEEN RECEIVED SO FAR IF
ANY AND PLEASE BE.
YOU KNOW ACCURATE IF YOU.
BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW.
OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
BROUGHT IN THIRTEEN GRIEF
COUNSELORS.
RECIEVE EMAILS DAILY.
FROM TEACHERS SAYING IT'S NOT
OUR HALF DAY OR IT'S NOT OUR DAY
THEY'RE RECEIVING TWO HALF DAYS
A WEEK.
I HAVE THIS CHILD SUFFERING
CHILDREN SUFFERING WHAT DO I DO
SO.
ARE COUNTY OFFICES WORKING VERY
VERY HARD.
THERE JUST ARE NOT ENOUGH
COUNSELORS TO OUR STUDENTS OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE TWO TO THREE HALF
DAYS A WEEK.
THANK YOU IN OUR DISTRICT WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY FUNDING FOR
COUNSELING AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD ADVOCATE FOR FUNDING FOR
THAT.
IMMEDIATE FUNDING AND THAT WE
ARE THANKFUL TO THE SUPPORT FOR
IT FROM THE COUNTY FROM
NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS FROM
HOSPICE BECAUSE THAT IS REALLY
WAS WHAT.
KEPT AS GOING THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
AT PINE ARE LIKE I SAID WE HAVE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS AND WE
HAVE -- FOR
COUNTLESS THREE THEIR ACADEMIC
COUNSELORS AND ONE THAT IS FROM
THE ESSAY WHY WHICH IS SOCIAL
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH COUNSELORS
ARE COUNCIL DO NOT ACADEMIC
COUNCIL AS MUCH AS THEY WOULD
LIKE -- TO
COLLEGE COUNCIL THEY ARE CRISIS
COUNSELORS THEY SPEND A LOT OF
THEIR TIME.
NOT ONLY DEALING WITH THE FIGHT
THE EFFECTS OF THE FIRES BUT FOR
THE SOCIO ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF
THE FIRES. TO TRY AND GET THE
KID FEMA RESOURCES HOUSING
RESOURCES WE HAVE A
PREDOMINANTLY HISPANIC COMMUNITY
SECOND LANGUAGE A LOT OF OUR
PARENTS DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH.
AND THEREFORE A LOT OF OUR
COUNSELORS ARE FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO NAVIGATE THE THE
SOCIAL SERVICES IN ORDER FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE COUNSELING
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT A HOME --
FOOD BANK [inaudible]
MEDICAL.
AT MY SCHOOL WE'VE HAD A
COUNSELOR THEIR FOUR DAYS A WEEK --
BUT THE CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL.
OUR STUDENTS ARE PRETTY
RESILIENT --
THEY'VE HAD A LOT OF ACES IN THE
BEGINNING HURT AND IN THEIR PAST
ANYWAY --
IT'S HO HUM BASICALLY.
OUR STATE OUR STAFF IS WORSE OFF
THAN OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT USED TO AS MUCH
DRAMA -- BUT
BEING PRESIDENT I'VE GOTTEN
QUITE A FEW EMAILS AS MUCH --
SUPERINTENDENT JOHN IS SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
THE SERVICES THAT THEY HAVE
THOSE DAYS THAT ARE THERE AND
THERE'S A LINE OUT THE DOOR FOR
THE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO THAT.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE GONE THEY'RE
NOT THERE --
THE STUDENTS ARE ARE SUFFERING --
TEACHERS ARE SUFFERING AS WELL
TEACHERS HAVE A HARD TIME
FINDING THE TIME.
TO UTILIZE THE SERVICES AS WELL --
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THE CLASSROOM
WITH STUDENTS ARE TRYING TO DO
THEIR FULL TIME JOB.
AND THE COUNCIL'S ARE GONE AFTER
SCHOOL SO YOU.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TIME THERE
SO IT THEY'RE TRYING TO WORK OUT
AT LEAST IN THE LE.
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE DOWN IN
LOWER IN THE VALLEY THE
CLASSROOMS HAVE MULTIPLE
TEACHERS PER ROOM SO THEY CAN --
GIVE THEM A BREAK AND GO YOU
ACCESS THOSE COUNSELING SERVICES --
BUT OF THE TWO SCHOOLS OF A
GALLEON DON'T HAVE THAT.
BENEFIT I GUESS --
TO BE ABLE.
TO STEP OUT OF THE CLASSROOM AND
AND UTILIZE SO SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR OTHER COMMON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
GALLAGHER --
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU EACH OF
YOU FOR YOUR POWERFUL TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING --
AT THIS AFTERNOON THAT MICHELLE.
QUICKLY COULD YOU SPEAK TO SOME
OF THE TRANSPORTATION.
IMPACTS FUNDING IMPACTS --
POSE THE FIRE.
I HAVE I REALLY HAVE NOT EVEN
ASKED OUR CBO PROPOSED FIRE
BECAUSE PRE FIRE WE WERE SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ENCROACHMENT ON OUR GENERAL FUND.
WE ARE DRY BEAN I KNOW WHEN I
VISIT THE SCHOOLS.
I DRIVE OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILES NOW TO REACH ALL OF
OUR SCHOOLS.
THE BUSES I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
FROM FOR YOU BUT THEY DRIVE
CHICO ORVILLE STERLING CITY
PARADISE.
THEY ARE DRIVING HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THIS AT ALL.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT HOPEFULLY.
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES WE HAVE
WE HAVE KIDS IN GRADE LAY AN
OUTLINE AREAS THAT WE JUST DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES OR THE
BUSES WE LOST SEVENTEEN OF OUR
VEHICLES.
IN THE FIRE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
REPLACED.
AND DUE TO ALL THE RED TAPE OF
GETTING VEHICLES REPLACED.
AND THEY ARE NOT REPLACED YET SO
IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU I I DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS I JUST HAVE A COMMENT
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
I'M PARTICULARLY DR ALSINA WHO'S
HERE FROM THE DISTRICT AND BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IN ADDITION
TO THE MIRACULOUS WORK THAT YOU
DID TO TRY TO GET THE
COMMUNITIES BACK IN --
YOU TO THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
BACK OPEN THAT.
THE OPENING OF THE SCHOOL.
WAS SO MUCH MORE AT TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED IT WASN'T SIMPLY TO
HELP INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS --
WHAT WE LEARNED IT WAS ABOUT
NORMALIZING LIFE FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY AND THAT?
I THINK ALSO SPEAKS TO HAVE BEEN
REALLY THE HEART OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE KNEW.
AND WHEN WE WERE GOING THROUGH
THE THOMAS FIRE AND THEN THE
SUBSEQUENT --
DEBRIS FLOWS THAT TO US GEDDINGS
KIDS IN SCHOOL WAS GOING TO BE
ONE OF THE HEALTHIEST THING WE
COULD DO FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE ALSO FOUND.
THAT PARENTS --
WERE EQUALLY IMPACTED BY THEIR
KIDS NOT BEING IN SCHOOL AND
THEIR ABILITY TO GET TO AND FROM
WHEREVER THEY NEEDED TO GO --
OR TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
DISASTER SO --
UNBELIEVABLE GRATITUDE TO ALL OF
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND CONTINUING TO SHARE THE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE -- WITH
NATURAL DISASTERS AND THE IMPACT
TO STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU --
WITHOUT THANK YOU I MISSED JOHN
MISTER SMITH CELL CENA AND MISS
MILLER THANK YOU.
I WILL NOW MOVE TO PANEL NUMBER.
TWO A LOCAL STATE RESOURCES AND
RESPONSE.
OUR NEXT PANEL WILL HIGHLIGHT.
THE STATE AND LOCAL RESPONSE TO
THESE FIRES I I HAVE INVITED
THESE AGENCY REPRESENTATIVES TO
SHARE BOTH THEIR SUCCESSES AND
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY BUT ALSO THEIR
CHALLENGES.
SO IF THAT PET NEXT PANEL COULD
COME UP FRONT PLEASE
[inaudible] TO LISTEN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY INTRODUCING A FAMILIAR FACE
TO THIS COMMITTEE --
WE MISS YOU WHO APPEARS OUT
BEFORE US TODAY IS A MISTER TONY
THURMOND SUPERINTENDENT OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION.
SO -- THANK
YOU FOR COMING OUT TO JOIN US
AND THEY'LL BE JOINED BY ONE
WIRELESS WHO ARE DIRECTOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
AND IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S REMARKS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM ERIC.
NUMBER ROOM ACT ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RESPONSE AND RECOVERY --
AND AND CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS
CHIEF HEADQUARTERS OPERATIONS
RESPONSE SECTION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THIS PANEL
ALSO -- WILL
CONCLUDE WITH REMARKS FROM MIKE
WALSH A TRUSTEE FOR THE BUTTE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION --
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN YOU MAY
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
BACK -- I
CERTAINLY WISH WAS UNDER
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES --
HEARING THAT TESTIMONY --
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT PREPARES YOU FOR
THAT THERE'S NOTHING THAT
PREPARES YOU. FOR LOSS OF A
LOVED ONE PHILOSOPHER HOME
PHILOSOPHER SCHOOL --
IN IS AS WE ALL HEARD HARD WORK
CONTINUES --
AND SO --
I'LL JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S STANCE BY.
ON TO OFFER SUPPORT TO THESE
DISTRICTS --
WE ARE LISTENING AND WE HERE --
AND HAVE HEARD THE CONCERNS FOR
MORE RESOURCES AND WE HAVE TRIED
TO CALL TOGETHER THE RESOURCES
THAT WE CAN. TO PROVIDE
COUNSELORS TO PROVIDE.
MORE SUPPORT AND MORE SUPPORT
FOR PREPARATION --
CLEARLY MORE IS NEEDED --
YOU ALL KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE
HOW MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES.
IN JUST A FEW MONTHS AND IN
BELIEVE A YEAR AND A HALF.
IN UNFORTUNATELY YOU WE KNOW
THAT NOW THIS IS THE WAY WE LIVE
THAT WE HAVE TO EXPECT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OUR STE THE
DIFFICULT LIKE THESE --
I I WANT TO THANK THE PREVIOUS
PANELISTS --
MITCHELL JOHN WE'VE HAD A CHANCE
TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH --
AND AND ARE TRYING TO OFFER
WHATEVER WE CAN --
TO BE SUPPORT OF OUR
SUPERINTENDENT --
AS YOU KNOW FROM MY TUXEDO AND
MISTER SMITH --
AND OUR TEACHER FROM APARTHEID
SWEET WE THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE SHARED AS HARD AS IT IS I
THINK WE HAVE TO LEARN FROM
THESE LESSONS.
ABOUT WHAT WE DO FOR IT --
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PRESENT ON THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL TO RETURN TO SCHOOL FOR
STUDENTS FROM PARADISE.
AND I WANNA THANK ALL THE FOLKS
FROM THE COMMUNITY FOR WELCOMING
US IT WAS OUR DAY --
EVERY PERSON THAT WE SPOKE TO
TOLD SCHRADER MAY THEY SAID THAT
THEY LOST EVERYTHING THAT THEY
LOST THEIR HOMES.
BUT THEY ALSO SAID THAT THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT. FOR
THE STUDENTS WHO CAME BACK TO
SCHOOL TO SEE A FAMILIAR FACE.
AND THEY PULLED IT TOGETHER --
TO SUPPORT.
THEIR STUDENTS THEY SHOWED THIS
COMMUNITY SHOWED.
THAT.
WE ARE RESILIENT AND WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES --
WE CAN OVERCOME --
NEARLY ANYTHING AND AS MANY OF
THE PARENTS SAID TO ME THAT DAY.
THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE BUTTE
STRONG ARE THAT THE REPAIRED I
STRONG.
AND WE STAND TO SUPPORT THEM.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WE'VE HAD TO LEARN ON THE JOB
ABOUT HOW TO SUPPORT.
COMMUNITIES THAT EXPERIENCE
DISASTER --
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE --
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
GROUPS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION --
AND OTHERS WHO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE FIND RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT.
THOSE THAT WE SERVE --
WE ARE THANKFUL FOR THE GRANT
THAT WE RECEIVE TO BE ABLE TO
BRING OUT SOME NEW STAFF AND YOU
HEAR ABOUT THAT --
WHOWORK SPECIFICALLY ON HOW WE
PREPARE --
FOR THE LIKELIHOOD OF DISASTERS
HOW DO WE SUPPORT AND RESPOND
AND THEN HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE JUST
AREN'T ENOUGH RESOURCES AS YOU
HEARD NO.
ONE NO ONE CONSIDERED THAT
THEY'D HAVE TO DEAL WITH
TRANSPORTATION COSTS --
THAT NOW MEAN YOU TRAVEL FURTHER
DISTANCES NO ONE CONSIDERED THE
NUMBER OF COUNCILLORS THAT YOU
MIGHT NEED TO ADDRESS GRIEF IN
THE MOMENT.
AND THEN THE RESPONSE BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE'S THE WAY YOU ARE
IN THE MOMENT AND THEN THERE'S
THE FOLLOW UP AFTERWARDS WHEN
YOU COME TO SCHOOL EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
AND YOU REALIZE YOU'VE LOST A
CLASSMATE YOU LOSS OF A LOVED
ONE YOU'VE LOST YOUR HOME.
WE ARE CqC PREPARED TO UTILIZE
EVERY RESOURCE AT OUR DISPOSAL
TO HELP THESE DISTRICTS AND HELP
FUTURE DISTRICTS --
WE NEED YOUR HELP QUITE FRANKLY
WE ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROPERLY
RESOURCE. TO SUPPORT.
THESE NEW DEMANDS AROUND
EDUCATION IT'S NOT SIMPLY SAYING
THAT WILL FIND PORTABLES --
OR ALTERNATIVE LOCATIONS --
WE LITERALLY HAVE TO FIGHT
TEMPORARY SCHOOL HOUSING NOW
YOU'VE HEARD TEACHER HOUSING --
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT AND THEN
TALK ABOUT HOW WE WE BUILD LONG
TERM GOING FORWARD --
OUR TEAM IS HERE TO SHARE WITH
YOU SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE SECURED.
WE LIKE TO ALSO PUT OUT AN
INVITATION THAT WE'VE CREATED --
TO DO A TRAINING IN A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
IN FOR EDUCATORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ON HOW TO PREPARE AND
RESPOND TO DISASTERS WERE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL HOST THAT.
ON MARCH THE SIX IT'S OPEN TO
ANY WE WELCOME PARTNERSHIP FROM
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE --
FROM THE ASSEMBLY --
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE HELP
OUR FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE --
AGAIN MY NAME IS JUANITA ELLIS
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES DIVISION.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
OUR ROLE IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOW BY NO WAY
ARE WE TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
DISASTERS THAT HAPPENED BEFORE.
BUT IT WASN'T TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THAT WE BAN BEGAN SEEN A NEW
KIND OF NORMAL FOR CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY IMPACTED OUR
SCHOOLS OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
STAFF.
BECAUSE OF THESE IMPACTS WE
DEVELOPED A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN OUR SUPPORT TO ELLIE
AIDS.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
THE TOTAL STATEWIDE IMPACTS
SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE WERE
TWELVE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
DESTROYED BY THE WILDFIRES THIS
INCLUDES PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
WE ALSO HAD AN ADDITIONAL
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS THAT WERE
DAMAGED AGAIN INCLUDES PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE.
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
LOST THEIR HOMES.
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED STAFF LOST
THEIR HOMES.
AGAIN THIS INFORMATION IS FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO PRESENT.
NOW IN OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS WAS OUR FIRST EXPERIENCE IN
LONG TERM ACTIVATION OF CD
REPRESENTATIVES.
AT THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
WHICH IS HOUSE AT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES HEADQUARTERS.
AND AND QUITE FRANKLY WE WERE
NOT WELL PREPARED.
WE WE HAD TO QUICKLY.
LEARN AND GET UP TO SPEED ON THE
EMERGEN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
WE HAD TO GET USED TO THE THE
THE SOCK SCHEDULES REPORTS WE
LEARNED A LOT.
WE LEARNED A LOT FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CALLAWAY YES AND I
THINK LIKEWISE THEY LEARN A LOT
FROM SUMMATION ABOUT SCHOOL
CLOSURES.
OF THE NUMBER STUDENTS DISPLACED
AND IMPACTS THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
IN THIS WAS CHALLENGING --
IT WAS CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT IT
WENT AGAINST THE NATURAL FLOW OF
INFORMATION.
NOW FIRST OF ALL THERE WERE ARE
NO REQUIREMENTS ARE STANDARD
PROCEDURES FOR ELLIE ETS TO
REPORT SCHOOL CLOSURES TO CD IN
REAL TIME --
SECOND WHAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
WAS IN NATURE LOCAL.
BECAUSE WE WERE LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION THAT WAS FROM INSIDE
AND IN THE PROXIMITY OF THE
BURNS OWNS.
WE SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE A WAY TO
GET THIS INFORMATION UNLESS WE
RECEIVED A DIRECTLY FROM SCHOOL
LEADERS --
OR FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND IF YOU WERE ACTIVE IN THE
RESPONSE FACE WE DEVELOPED A
VERY STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALLAWAY YES.
SINCE SCHOOLS WHERE PRIORITY NOT
JUST FOR OUR DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THIS LED TO CITIES FIRST
PARTICIPATION IN THE UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP.
WHICH IS MADE UP OF HIGH LEVEL
STATE AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A STATE
SCHOOLS TASK FORCE --
JOINTLY LED BY OUR OFFICE AND
CAL YES.
IN THIS TASK FORCE BASICALLY
PROVIDED A COLLABORATIVE FORUM
FOR STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES
TO PRIORITIZE EFFECTIVE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPACT THAT ELLIE ACE.
AND WE HAD SOME SOME RESULTING
SUCCESSES FROM THE STATE'S WAS
TASK FORCE --
FOR EXAMPLE THE CREATION AND
DISSEMINATION WHILE FIVE
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS THAT
WERE SPECIFIC TO SCHOOLS.
WE DEVELOPED THAT WE PUT HER ON
A WEBSITE --
PERON CALLOW YES IS WEBSITE.
WE ALSO ESTABLISH A DEPLOYED.
AN INTERAGENCY SCHOOL ASSESSMENT
TEAM.
THAT WAS LED BY OUR DEPARTMENT
TO HELP THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED BUT BUT
THEY WERE NEAR --
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE
DESTROYED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON WHAT TO
DO TO REOPEN SCHOOLS.
THERE WAS NO STATE.
LAWS REGULATION TOGETHER IT
SEEMED OR GO OUT THERE AND TRY
AND HELP THEM --
THIS ALSO RESULT IN
COLLABORATION TO ISSUE A
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THAT CREATED FOR CIVILIAN
SECURITY FOR IMPACTED ELLIE ACE.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORTED THE CINEMA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
CONVENING A LOCAL SCHOOLS TASK
FORCE.
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE THE
STATE BUT THIS IS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
RECORDED DAILY WITH A SCHOOL
LIAISON THAT WAS EMBEDDED IN THE
COUNTY EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER --
AND THERE WERE THERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CINEMA COUNTY SCHOOLS.
SOMETHING THAT WE LEARN FROM
THIS WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING.
A SCHOOL LIAISONS REPRESENTED
DAILY AT THE COUNTY EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
THIS ADDRESSES THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION THAT GOES FROM THE
LOCALS TO THE COUNTY TO THE
STATE.
AND INSURERS AND EDUCATION VOICE
IS AT THE TABLE.
THROUGHOUT THE PER SPONSOR
PROCESS AND TO ADDRESS ANY ON
THAT NEEDS.
NOW WHILE ACTIVITIES CONTINUED
IN THE FIELD OFFICE CITY WORKED
WITH THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY AND SECURE FUNDING
FOR SEVERAL GRANTS --
SOMEBODY'S GRANTS OR THE PROJECT
SERVE WHICH IS A SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE OF ISLANDS
THE RESTART PROGRAM.
WHICH IS A AID TO RESTART SCHOOL
OPERATIONS THE EMERGENCY IMPACT
AID AND ASSISTANCE FOR HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
NOW AS A RESULT OF THE GREAT
WORK FROM OUR FORMER FEDERAL
LIAISON WHO IS NOW PART OF YOUR
COMMITTEE THINKING --
CALIFORNIA WAS ABLE TO APPLY
SECURED NINETEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO ASSIST
ELEAZAR.
AYE WITH REBUILDING STUDENT
TRANSPORTATION COUNSELING
TEMPERATE FACILITIES AND MORE.
THESE FUNDS ARE USED TO
SUPPLEMENT INSURANCE AND FOR YOU
MY PUBLIC ASSISTANT DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS ELEAZAR UNMET NEEDS.
NOW SHORTLY AFTER THE OCTOBER
INCIDENT WAS STABILIZED.
THEN THE THOMAS FIRE MOST OTHERS
RAVAGED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LATER ON THAT MONTH.
WE HAD TO WANT TO SEE THE MUD
SLIDES WHICH WE HEARD ABOUT
EARLIER.
AND THIS CREATED A WHOLE NEW SET
OF TASKS AROUND WORKING WITH
IMPACTED ELLIE ETS TO A JENNIFER
I OPTIONS FOR AN ARM HELLSING.
AND TEMPORARY SITE LOCATIONS.
OUR INFORMATION GATHERING
SAPPORO REMAIN LARGELY THE SAME.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO WORK MORE
QUICKLY. TO CONNECT IMPACTED
ELLIE ACE TO THE RESOURCES.
THEY WOULD GET TO THE JULY
AUGUST WILDFIRES THAT IN SOME
CASES DEVASTATED COUNTRIES THAT
WERE IMPACTED THE YEAR BEFORE.
DURING THESE FIRES THE EDUCATION
LEADERS AFFECTED BY THE ACT OF
MERCY THEY HAD THE BENEFIT OF
LEARNING FROM THEIR PEERS.
WHO HAD BEEN THROUGH THE SAME
THING?
WE WOULD LIKE --
TO THINK DOCTOR STEVEN PARENTING
IN PARTICULAR FOR THE EXPERTISE
HE HAS LED TO FELLOW COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY.
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE CAMPFIRE
RESULT IN A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
RESPONSE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THE CITY TEAM DREW UPON THEIR
PAST EXPERIENCE IN ORDER TO BE
DILIGENTLY PROACTIVE ABOUT
IDENTIFIED I'M AT LOCAL NEEDS.
AND WE DID HAVE SOME SUCCESSES --
IN THIS EFFORT.
WE ONCE AGAIN RESUMED THE
STATE'S SCHOOLS TASK FORCE --
AGAIN BEING CALLED LED BY OUR
PARTNERS AND OURSELVES I CAL YES.
WE DEPLOYED A TEAM OF CD EXPERTS.
TO HELP THE BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION IS EDUCATION SUMMIT.
WE ALSO HELP IN SECURING AND
ORGANIZING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
VOLUNTEERS --
TO HELP STUDENTS TO AS A RETURN
TO SCHOOL --
THIS ALSO RESULT IN
COLLABORATION WITH CALLAWAY YES
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
SECURE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS.
THAT MET LOCAL NEEDS SUCH AS
BEING ABLE TO USE TEMPORARY
FACILITIES.
NOW THROUGHOUT THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE WILD FIRES RESPONSE.
WE HAVE BOLSTERED ON MY GUIDANCE
AND ARE RICHER FOR SILLY ETS
IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES.
PROVIDING INFORMATION ON
ATTENDANCE AND FUNDING FOOD
DISTRIBUTION CONGREGATE FEEDING --
ANTS SCHOOL FACILITIES SOLUTIONS
BUT UNDERSTAND THE LOCAL NEEDS
AND TAKEN ACTION TO SUPPORT THE
LA ACE.
NOW WHILE INTERAGENCY
COLLABORATION CORONATION HAS
GROWN TREMENDOUSLY --
AND LET TO FOUNDATIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WE STILL FACE SOME
PERSISTENT CHALLENGES WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TASK OF SUPPORTING.
SOME OF THE ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS
BETTER OUT ONE CALIFORNIA STATE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PLAN.
WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
HELPING ELEAZAR DURING THE
RESPONSE OF RECOVERY.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN HELPING ELLIE ACE
PREPARE FOR EMERGENCIES --
AS A STATES INTERACTION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO
SUPPORT ELEAZAR THEIR WITH THAT
WE CAN.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CAROL YES
ANOTHER AGENCIES.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE --
TO RESOURCES SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY I'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT.
REPEAT SOME OF WHAT --
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND AND ONE
TOUCHED ON BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE DON'T WITH
STATEWIDE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WHAT OUR ROLE IS
AND CAL WE*. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CERTAINLY
EXPECT IS AHEAD OF US --
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS YEAR AS
WELL TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS A REAL
ROSA.
WE THOUGHT WAS A REMARKABLE YEAR
IT WAS BOOKENDED.
BY TWO OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS THAT WE DEALT WITH AND
DECADE STUCK --
SIGNIFICANT FLOODING IN THE
EARLY PART --
THE LARGEST NON HURRICANE
EVACUATION IN U. S. HISTORY --
FOLLOWING THE EMERGENCY --
AT LAKE OR A BILL AT THE END OF
THAT YEAR WE DEALT WITH WHAT WE
BELIEVED WAS --
NOT TO BE SURPASSED --
IN MANY MANY YEARS --
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ACROSS
SEVEN COUNTIES FOURTEEN FIRES
THAT ALL STARTED ON OCTOBER
EIGHTH AND DEVASTATED --
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS ONE
INDICATED --
FOLLOWED BY THE THOMAS FIRE.
SO AS WE GOT INTO.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN A WE WERE FACED
UNFORTUNATELY --
WITH ANOTHER SERIES OF
CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS IN TOTAL
ACROSS.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WERE
SIXTEEN PROP GOVERNOR'S
PROCLAMATIONS OF EMERGENCIES.
INCLUDED IN THERE --
WERE THREE A PRESIDENTIAL
DISASTER DECORATIONS MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATIONS.
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO RECEIVED
TWELVE FIRE MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE GRANTS WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT THAT ARE THOSE
WERE TWELVE INCIDENTS WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
ASSISTANCE TO TRY TO AVOID.
HAVING A CATASTROPHIC WILD FIRE
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THOSE
FIRES DID BECOME SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THE MINUS SEAT SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED SIGNIFICANT FIRES.
THROUGHOUT ALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN OF THOSE
REQUIRED US TO ACTIVATE THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER.
AS HAS BEEN NOTED EARLIER THAT
IS THE LOCATION WHERE WE HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
MOBILIZING STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE IMPACTED.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CAR FIRE
IN SHASTA AND TRINITY COUNTIES --
INCLUDED A CAP THREE FIRE NATO A
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED PREVIOUSLY WITH A
HUNDRED FORTY MILE FORTY THREE
MILE AN HOUR WINDS DRIVING THAT
FIRE.
THAT WAS A FIRE THAT NIGHT WE
BELIEVE THAT WAS LIKELY GOING TO
RUN -- TO
INTERSTATE FIVE BUT FORTUNATELY
FIRE CREWS WERE ABLE TO DO
REMARKABLE WORK AND STOP IT
BEFORE IT DEVASTATED --
THE CITY OF READING WE HAD THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE A SERIES
OF FIRES THAT CAME TOGETHER AND
COLUSA GLENN LAKE AND MENDOCINO
COUNTIES.
ULTIMATELY --
THOSE --
BECAME THE LARGEST FIRE
SURPASSING THE THOMAS FIRE FROM
JUST MONTHS PREVIOUS TO THAT.
AT THE END OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS
WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE WE
EXPERIENCE THE CAMPFIRE AND
BUTTE THE HILL FIRED VENTURE ON
THE WALLS THE FIRE IN LOS
ANGELES.
ALL TOLD.
WE LOST A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE FIRES
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEARLY TWO
MILLION ACRES WERE DESTROYED.
AND TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED --
INCLUDING SEVERAL OF OUR
CRITICAL SCHOOLS IN THE CAMP
FIRE SO WE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
UNDER THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT
OF MOBILIZING.
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
SUPPORT AND WE DO THAT THROUGH
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER THE
ROOM THAT WE ACTIVATE WE
MOBILIZE AGENCIES AND WITH RICK
SPECIFIC RESPONSIBILITIES TASK
TO THEM. TO HELP ADDRESS
PARTICULAR CASCADING EFFECTS AND
CA AND THE CONSEQUENCE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE MAJOR THAT'S
AND AS WAS NOTED EARLIER THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STAFF.
DID A PHENOMENAL JOB OF STEPPING
UP TO A TASK THAT THEY HADN'T
PREVIOUSLY --
BEEN HANDED TO COME TOGETHER
WORKING CLOSELY WITH US. TO
ADDRESS THE INCREDIBLY UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT THE SCHOOLS WERE
FACING DURING THESE EVENTS --
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER AND
AND LAST YEAR WAS ACTIVATED FOR
A HUNDRED AND ONE DAYS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE ARE
ACTIVATED FOR A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN DAYS.
WHEN WE ACTIVATE THE DIRECTOR
FORMS A UNIFIED COORDINATING
GROUP OF SENIOR LEADERS FROM
ACROSS NOT ONLY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION --
BUT AS IS HAS BEEN ILLUSTRATED
BY OUR PARTNERS A DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICE --
OFFICE HOLDERS --
THAT PLAY KEY ROLES ACTED THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY IN THE CASE OF THE CAMP
HILL HOLES HE FIRES.
WE WITHIN HOURS HAD AN INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM FROM THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY
MOBILIZED BEFORE WE EVEN HAD A
MAJOR DISASTER DECLARATION.
SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO IS BUILT
UPON THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE
BEEN FORMED BETWEEN OUR SENIOR
LEADERS.
BOTH THE CALLAWAY YES CAL FIRE
THE ADJUTANT GENERAL THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
IN A REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR AT
FEMA THOSE INDIVIDUALS COMING
TOGETHER --
DEMONSTRATING --
LEADERSHIP AND MOVING THE STATE
FORWARD HAS ALLOWED US TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TIME AND
AGAIN. TO THE SIGNIFICANT EVENTS.
WHAT WE FIND DURING THESE EVENTS
IS THE NEED TO FORM CRITICAL
TASK FORCES TO REALLY ZERO IN ON
PARTICULAR CONSEQUENCE
MANAGEMENT EFFORTS AND DURING
THE CAMP HILL AND WE'LL SEE
FIRES?
WE ACTIVATED SEVEN DIFFERENT
TASK FORCES TO DEAL WITH
SHELTERING IN HOUSING ISSUES
WHICH WHICH WERE USED TO DEALING
WITH --
DEALING WITH ISSUES AFFECTING --
ANIMALS THAT ARE DISPLACED BY
THESE EVENTS THE WATERSHED
IMPACTS THE DEBRIS IMPACTS BUT
ON THIS PARTICULAR OF THAT
FORMED A SCHOOLS TASK FORCES
WELL. TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE WERE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AND
ADDRESSING THE IMPACTS TO THE
SCHOOLS.
IN A WERE USED TO ON THE SCHOOL
IMPACTS DEALING WITH THE AIR
QUALITY CONCERNS AS WE GET THESE
MAJOR FIRES IN THE SMOKE STARTS.
TO MIGRATE THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
THE IMPACT TO SCHOOLS WE
CERTAINLY SITE LAST LAST YEAR IS
WIDESPREAD.
BUT WHAT WE NEEDED --
TO DOUBLE DOWN ON IN TERMS OF
OUR EFFORTS WAS THE IMPACT OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHAT IT
WAS GOING TO MEAN.
TO RELOCATE REBUILD AND AND MOVE
ASIANS AROUND --
IN THIS EVENT WE STOOD UP THE
SCHOOLS TASK FORCE WE MOBILIZE
STAFF FROM CALLAWAY US ALONG
WITH DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
STAFF.
DOWN INTO THE FIELD TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH OUR PARTNERS BUILT
AT THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION'S AS WELL AS WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH LOCAL
SUPERINTENDENTS.
HAS WON SAID WE TOOK
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS TO UTILIZE
THE POWERS.
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS TO PUT
INTO EXECUTIVE ORDERS --
WAIVERS I'VE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ROAD BLOCKS --
THAT WERE NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND MY PARTNER
CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS WILL TALK
AND LITTLE GREATER DETAIL ABOUT
WHAT OUR TASK FORCE WAS CHARGED
WITH.
WHAT WE'RE CERTAINLY SEEING AS A
RESULT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE CLEAR
CLIMB IN A LOGICAL IMPACTS WERE
DEALING WITH IN CALIFORNIA?
IS AN ABSOLUTE NEW NORMAL
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE EVERY
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
DEAL WITH IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN MUCH OF THE SAME
IN TERMS OF EVENTS AND IMPACTS
THAT WE'VE DEALT WITH IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND WE ARE MAKING TREMENDOUS
STRIDES ACROSS.
THE BOTH THE FIRST RESPONDER --
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT EDUCATION
SPECTRUM. TO TO IS TO TO IMPROVE
OUR READINESS AND POSTURE --
BUT THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE AS SUPER FORCED YOUR
SCHOOLS PROFESSIONALS ARE ARE
THAT THEY ARE EDUCATORS THEY ARE
PROFESSIONALS AND THERE'S NOBODY
BETTER.
AT EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN --
BUT THEY'RE NOT EMERGENCY
MANAGERS AND SO COLLECTIVELY --
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OUR PARTNERS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IN OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS OFFICIALS. TO HELP THEM
BE PREPARED TO DEAL WITH NOT
JUST THE SCHOOL CLOSURES THAT
COME FROM THESE TYPES OF EVENTS
BUT THE CASCADING HIM PACKS
HELPING THEM TO IDENTIFY THOSE.
AND DO THE PRE PLANNING
NECESSARY SO THAT WE CAN MOVE IT
OUT FAR.
FASTER PACE AS THESE EVENTS
UNFOLD IN THE FUTURE SO THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON I WAS ONCE YOU
MY NAME IS CAROLINE THOMAS
JACOBS AND I'M THE CHIEF OF
CALLUSES HEADQUARTERS OPERATIONS
FOR RESPONSE WHICH INCLUDES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSEEING
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
DURING ARMOR AGENCIES.
SO OPPOSITE OPERATIONS THAT ARE
AS BEEN REFERENCED WE STAND UP
THE SCHOOLS TASK FORCE WHEN
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
DAMAGE TO IN ORDER STRUCTURE AND
TO SCHOOLS DURING AN EVENT --
AS WAS REFERENCED EARLIER BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN --
Là MON WE RECOGNIZE AT THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER THAT
BRINGING THE THE STUDENTS BACK
TO SCHOOL IN IN WHATEVER
CAPACITY THAT IS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO REBUILDING THE
COMMUNITY AND WE START THAT AS
SOON AS THE RESPONSES ACTUALLY
ACTIVATED.
SO THE SCHOOLS TASK FORCE
GENERALLY FOCUSES ON K. THROUGH
TWELVE GRADES UP FOR THE PURPOSE
OF RETURNING STUDENTS TO THE
CLASSROOM AND RESTORING
RESTORING SCHOOL OPERATIONS. FOR
THE COMMUNITY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
SPECIFICALLY THE STORE SCHOOL
TASK FORCE MISSION IS TO SUPPORT
THE AFFECTED COUNTY OR COUNTIES
OFFICES OF EDUCATION LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IN INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE WITH
ASSISTANCE IDENTIFYING AND
IMPLEMENTING SOLUTIONS TO
EXPEDITE REPAIR REMEDIATION RE
OPENING AND RE POPULATION OF
LOCAL SCHOOLS AND EARLY EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS.
THE TASK FORCE ALSO ASSIST
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AS NEEDED.
OUR CRE MEMBERSHIP --
ON THE STATE PARTNER SITE
INCLUDES OF COURSE IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
IN THE OTHER DIVISION OF STATE
ARCHITECTS PLAYS A KEY COMPONENT
ON THE TASK FORCE.
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THEN WE BRING IN ADDITIONAL
STATE AGENCIES AS AS NECESSARY
WE ALSO INCLUDE ON THE TASK
FORCE FEDERAL PARTNERS WITH OUR
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY FEMA.
AS WELL AS THE U. S. ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS AS NEEDED
SPECIFICALLY AROUND DEBRIS
OPERATIONS.
KEY OBJECTIVES OF THE TASK FORCE
ARE CONNECTING SCHOOL OFFICIALS
WITH THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER.
PROVIDING EXPERT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO EXPEDITE SCHOOL
CLEAN UP AND RETURNING SCHOOLS
RETURNING STUDENTS TO SCHOOL SO
AS WAS REFERENCE FOR EXAMPLE ON
THE CAMPFIRE THE TASK FORCE
PROVIDED TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ON
SPACE PLANNING.
IN ASSISTING WITH LOCATING
PORTABLES TO FACILITATE
RETURNING STUDENTS TO SCHOOLS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
ACTORS ALSO INCLUDE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE REGARDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS SO
WAS ALSO REFERENCE BACK IN THE
TUBS FIRE IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE SCHOOLS
TASK FORCE ASSEMBLED FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
A SAFETY ASSESSMENT TEAM THAT
WAS MADE UP OF VARIOUS TECHNICAL
EXPERTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCY FAMILY A WHO PROVIDED
SCHOOL OFFICIALS --
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO INFORM
THEIR DECISION MAKING ON HOW --
TO SAFELY RE OPEN THE SCHOOLS
QUICKLY AFTER THE FIRES.
THE OBJECTIVES ALSO INCLUDE --
IDENTIFYING ISSUES THAT REQUIRE
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM THE
GOVERNOR IN ORDER TO WAIVE
SPECIFIC RULES AND REGULATIONS.
IDENTIFYING AND SEEKING
AVAILABLE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
TO HELP ELIGIBLE SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN RESTORE OPERATIONS.
IDENTIFYING AND SOURCING SHORT
AND LONG TERM NEEDS UNMET NEEDS
SUCH AS TRAUMA COUNSELING WHICH
WAS REFERRED TO IN OTHER
TESTIMONY EARLIER AT SUCH A
CRITICAL COMPONENT --
IN ASSISTING SCHOOLS WITH
NAVIGATING THE DEBRIS REMOVAL
PROCESS IN FEMA PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROCESS THAT IS SO
CRITICAL TO THEM BEING ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE RESOURCES TED
QUICKLY RE OPEN.
SO OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS CALORIE S. IS
DEVELOPED A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND WE
THANK THEM FOR THEIR ACTIVE
SUPPORT.
IN THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
IN STRONG PARTNERSHIP ON THE
SCHOOLS TASK FORCE AS THESE
DISASTERS CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
WE'RE OF ALL THE MATURING THE
TOOLS IN THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT --
THAT WE'RE BUILDING TO LEVERAGE
AND EFFECTIVELY TO THE NEEDS OF
SCHOOLS DURING DISASTERS SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY --
AND YOUR INTEREST IN THIS
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO REBUILDING
A COMMUNITY AFTER DISASTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
DONALD MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING AND
PROVIDE ME TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH YOU --
ONE SURE MY PERSPECTIVE AS A
BUTTE COUNTY TRUSTEE --
AT THE TIME OF THE ARE FIRED THE
CAMPFIRE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
AND ALSO AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER
THE TOWN OF ORVILLE --
WE ARE COUNTY OF JUST OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT
ARE SPREAD AMONG FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS AND SIXTEEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
ON THE HOME PAGE OF OUR WEBSITE
THE FIRST HITTING YOU WILL READ
IS WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE
SUCCESS OF EVERY STUDENT.
AND THE EXCELLENCE OF EVERY
EDUCATOR --
AS A COUNTY BOARD WE'VE ALWAYS
TAKEN A SPECIAL SENSE OF PRIDE
IN HELPING THOSE THAT STRUGGLE
THE MOST AND HAVE THE FEWEST
RESOURCES ACCOMPLISH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND FIND
MEANINGFUL WORK.
AND FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION.
SO LAST YEAR AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE STATE OF CS BE A IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AS THE PRESIDENT
ELECT I LIKE SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLEWATCHED IN DISBELIEF AND
SHOCK.
AT THE WILD FIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS IS THE IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT DEVASTATED
SONOMA COUNTY TO THE CAR FIRE
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN I HEARD
FIRST HAND FROM BOARD MEMBERS.
ACROSS THE STATE JUST A HEART
BREAKING IT IS THEY HAVE
STUDENTS AND FAMILY LOSE
EVERYTHING IN THE BLINK OF AN
EYE.
AT C. S. B. A. WE INTERVIEWED
BOARD MEMBERS AND SUPERINTENDENT
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGES OF REBUILDING AND
HELP OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
REPAIR IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT --
THEY WERE RAVAGED BY DISASTER IN
IN OUR PUBLICATION CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS TRIAL BY FIRE.
THIS ONE ISSUE THAT YOU GAVE
TIPS LIKE INSURE COMMUNICATIONS
AND UPDATES ARE AVAILABLE IN
LANGUAGES COMMONLY SPOKEN.
OFFER REFUGE TO NON STUDENTS AND
SERVICE COMMUNITY SHELTER
PREPARE FOR DONATIONS.
HELP FIND KAREN ACTIVITY FOR
CHILDREN SCHOOLS ARE CLOSE.
I READ THIS ARTICLE AS IT CAME
OUT WAS A PART OF THIS IN STILL
NONE OF THAT FULLY PREPARED ME
FOR THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
CAMPFIRE.
HAS A RESIDENT OF OROVILLE WE
FOUND OURSELVES DEALING WITH
EMERGENCY EVACUATIONS MORE THAN
WE HAVE CARE TO EXPERIENCE OF
THE PAST TWO YEARS --
SO WHEN THEY CAN'T FIRE FORCED
THE ENTIRE TOWNS OF PARADISE AND
CON COUNTY VACUUM WAIT.
IT ONLY SEEMS NATURAL TO PROVIDE --
COMFORT TO OUR NEIGHBORS THOSE
IT SUDDENLY FOUND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS AND DEVASTATED WERE
FRIENDS OF MINE.
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
AND COLLEGE.
THEY WERE WORK COLLEAGUES THAT I
COME TO KNOW AND CARE.
FOR FROM JOBS THAT I'VE HELD
OVER THE YEARS.
IN SOME OF THEM WERE THE
STUDENTS THAT I'VE COACHED IN
SPORTS THERE ARE NOW RAISING
THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
I WASN'T FULLY PREPARED THIS
TIME BECAUSE THE STORY WAS
HAPPENING TO THE PEOPLE THAT I
CONSIDER MY FAMILY.
ALL THAT MATTERED IN THAT MOMENT
IS THAT WE THEY WERE IN NEED AND
WE WERE ABLE TO HELP.
I'M GONNA GIVE CREDIT TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE BICU COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE TIME WAS
TIM TAYLOR.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO FULLY
EXPRESS WELL IT IS DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO FULLY EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
AS I WATCHED HIM IN MARY SUE
COLEMAN WHO WAS THE
SUPERINTENDENT ELECT AT THE TIME.
IS THEY RESPONDED TO THESE
TRAGEDIES THERE OUTSIDE AND
DETERMINATION TO LIVE UP TO OUR
RULE OF STUDENTS FIRST.
I'D FIND GREAT LEADERSHIP IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD PEOPLE BY
LOVING THEM IN TO SAY PEOPLE BY
SERVING THEM.
THERE WAS NO BETTER EXAMPLE WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE.
THEN TO WATCH THE ACTIONS OF
BOTH TIM MERRY.
THEY MADE TOUGH DECISIONS LIKE
CLOSING.
EXCUSE ME.
MY CLOSING ALL SCHOOLS LOCATED
IN BICU COUNTY FOR THREE WEEKS.
IT WAS NOT ONLY DUE TO THE
INCREDIBLY TOXIC AND THEN
HEALTHY AIR QUALITY.
BUT IT WAS ALSO BECAUSE OF THE
MASSIVE UNDERTAKING REQUIRED TO
COORDINATE THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND RELOCATION OF OVER
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS AND STAFF.
THEY SOUGHT THE HELP IN THE
ADVICE OF COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION IN THE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACT IN THE PAST BY
WILDFIRES.
INCLUDING HAVING SOME OF THEIR
STAFF ACTUALLY LEAD OUR EFFORTS.
IN RETROSPECT I FIND NOW THAT
I'M EVEN STRONGER MY CONVICTION
TODAY THAN THE DAY THEY MADE
THOSE DECISIONS IN THAT FIRST
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
IN THAT THEY WERE EXACTLY WHAT
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
AGAIN ALL DECISIONS ARE MADE IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WAS BETTER IN
EDUCATORS. FOR THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS ARE ONLY FOCUS AT THE
BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WAS FINDING A WAY TO RE CONNECT
STUDENTS WITH THEIR TEACHERS.
THE CHALLENGE FOR US IS THAT OUR
STUDENTS WERE DISPLACED WITH
ALMOST EVERYONE OF THEM HAVING
NO HOME TO RETURN TO AFTER THE
EVACUATIONS WERE LIFTED AND
NEARLY AN ENTIRE TOWN.
HAVING BEEN TAKEN OFF THE MAP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
THAT MEANT THAT EVERY STUDENT
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL OR CHARTER
SCHOOL PUBLIC OR PRIVATE SCHOOL
WAS IN CRISIS.
AND WE CHOSE TO SERVE THE MALL.
EACH BOARD MEMBER IS WARMER TOOK
ON A DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
SUCH AS HELPING COORDINATE
TRAUMA SUPPORT.
UPDATING OTHER STATE AGENCIES
AND WORKING WITH STATE
LEGISLATORS TO SECURE LONG TERM
FUNDING.
ONCE AGAIN MY HEART SWELLED WITH
PRIDE AS A DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
COUNTY RESPONDED IN LIKE FASHION.
I TAKE PRIDE KNOWING THAT THE
ORDEAL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT DID WHAT THEY COULD TO
RELOCATE THEIR STUDENTS ACROSS
THE DISTRICT.
SO THE PARADISE STUDENTS.
COULD REMAIN TOGETHER AND
RECONNECT WITH EACH OTHER.
AND THEIR TEACHERS AND BEGIN TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES IN SOME
SENSE OF NORMALCY AT THEIR NEW
HOME.
FORMALLY KNOWN AS BIRCH STREET
SCHOOL.
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
SCHOOL IT'S LOCATED DIRECTLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM MY OWN
HOME.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE SCHOOLS THAT
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN VISITED
ON THAT SECOND FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL.
AS I WATCHED HIM JUST SHARE
BREAKFAST WITH THE STUDENTS --
FOR ME IT'S A GIFT EVERY DAY
THAT I IT WHENEVER I'M HOME THAT
I HAVE A REMINDER OF WHY I SERVE.
IN WIRE WORK HERE TODAY ACTUALLY
MATTERS.
AS ONE BOARD MEMBER WAS QUOTED
IN OUR ARTICLE FROM THE SANTA
BARBARA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
REMINDED US.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE THE HEART OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OFTEN THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU --
AND SURROUNDS YOU BROUGHT UP A
POINT THAT I HADN'T THOUGHT OF
REALLY THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE I
KNOW MY OWN CITY I SERVED ON THE
CITY COUNCIL OR JUST UNDER
ELEVEN YEARS.
AND WE HAD OUR OWN EMERGENCY OP
BE ACTIVATED DURING A VARIETY
EVENTS BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS PRESENT.
AND THAT EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER THAT THAT MEANT SOMETHING.
I THINK I NEED TO ASK IT WAS
VERY VERY USEFUL --
DURING THE CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE
OF THAT --
PARTICIPATION BECAUSE IT
PROVIDED DIRECT LINK FROM THE
LOCALS TO THE COUNTY --
SEE AND AGAIN IF THERE IS ANY
UNMET NEEDS THERE THEN THEY
WOULD BE ELEVATED TO US AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO SEE WHAT WE COULD
DO TO HELP.
I GUESS YOU YOU TWO REALLY ARE
THE FIRST ONES THAT.
THAT DID THAT THAT'S AT THE
STATE LEVEL RIGHT WE WEREN'T
THERE WASN'T A PLACE FOR
EDUCATION PRIOR TO THIS THERE
WASN'T MAYBE EVEN IF I NOTED
NEED.
BUT I THINK THAT WHERE THIS IS
NOW THERE AND IT'S HAVE --
IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THE
IMPACTS OF BEEN GREATER TO
SCHOOLS HAT A CREATED A A
GREATER LEVEL OF SUPPORT AT THE
STATE LEVEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATE COMES THANK YOU VERY
INFORMATIVE THANK YOU ALL.
OUR NEXT PANEL IS --
TO A LESSONS LEARNED AND POLICY
QUESTIONS.
BUT CAN WE TAKE AWAY FROM THIS
HEARING REALLY --
TODAY'S FINAL PANEL INCLUDES
MANY OF THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION IT SERVED IN A
COORDINATING ROLE.
IN THE RESPONSE OF RECOVERY FAIR
PHASES.
OF WILD THE WILDLIFE RESPONSE
THEY WILL FOCUS ON LESSONS
LEARNED.
AND POLICY QUESTIONS FOR THIS
BODY THIS LEGISLATURE.
GOING FORWARD IN OUR PANELISTS
TODAY ARE.
IS -- A
STEVEN TO ID HARRINGTON
SUPERINTEND OF THE CINEMA COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EDUCATION STANLEY
MANTOOTH SUPERINTENDENT OF
VENTURA.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION JUDY
FLOORS SUPERINTENDENT OF SHASTA
COUNTY SIKU A SUPERINTENDENT OF
BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WHICH I SPENT SOME TIME WITH.
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO UP NORTH
SO WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH A MISTER
HARRINGTON.
MUCH THANK YOU --
CHAIRPERSON O'DONNELL AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
AS THE NUMBER COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS IT'S AN
HONOR TO SHARE WITH YOU THE
LESSONS LEARNED.
AND RESPONDING TO CINEMA
COUNTIES TUBS FIRE.
AS WELL AS MY EXPERIENCE HOLDING
OTHER EDUCATIONAL LEADERS.
AND HELPING OTHER OTHER
EDUCATIONAL IS WITH A SIMILAR
CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS.
I COMMEND YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING SO THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AGENCIES CAN BE BETTER PREPARED
TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND THE
CHILDREN IN THE NEXT DISASTER
STRIKES WHEN THE NEXT DISASTER
STRIKES.
IN CINEMA COUNTY NORTH OF SAN
FRANCISCO MY OFFICE IS PRIVILEGE
TO SERVE. FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
PROVIDE CARE AND EDUCATION FOR
MORE THAN SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
SOME DISTRICTS ARE SMALL IN
RURAL SERVING AS FEW AS TEN
STUDENTS WHILE OTHERS ARE LARGE
AND URBAN.
WE ARE HOME TO A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE SCHOOLS FIFTY SIX
OF WHICH ARE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MOST OF THOSE ARE DEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS MEANING THEY
FUNCTION AS PART OF THE DISTRICT.
ONE COUNTRY IS ASSOCIATED WITH
WEALTH.
BUT ABOUT 45% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED.
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OUR COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCE THE TUBS FIRE.
AT AT THAT TIME IT WAS THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
IN MORE THAN FORTY YEARS FORTY
SIX YEARS I HAVE WORKED IN
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I HAVE RESPONDED TO NUMEROUS
FLOODS AND EARTHQUAKES IN MY
THIRTY SIX YEARS AS
SUPERINTENDENT.
BUT I'VE NEVER SEEN A NATURAL
DISASTER TAKE SUCH A TOLL ON
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY AS TO THE
TYPES FOR WILDFIRE.
THE WILDFIRES SWEPT THROUGH INTO
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA OVERNIGHT.
LEAPING OVER SIX LANE FREEWAY.
AND OVERWHELMING OUR EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
IT DESTROYED NUMEROUS SCHOOL
SITES AND THE HOMES OF NEARLY
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EDUCATORS AND OUR MOST IMPACTED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE'RE CLOSE WE'RE JUST DISTRICTS
WERE CLOSED FOR THREE WEEKS AS
THEY DEALT WITH THE AFTERMATH.
TWO SCHOOLS COULD NOT REOPEN FOR
FOUR MONTHS.
BECAUSE OF TOXIC DEBRIS IN ASH
HAD TO BE CLEARED FROM THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD THE ONLY THING
STANDING WAS THE SCHOOL.
SINCE IT THEN AS YOU KNOW
SIMILAR WILDFIRES HAVE BURNED
INTO OTHER COMMUNITIES CAUSING
ANY MORE DEVASTATION.
I'VE COME IN THE EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS FOR CINEMA BEAUTE SHASTA
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES.
AND THE OTHER IMPACTED AS THEY
RESPONDED QUICKLY WITH THE
INNOVATION.
OF THESE UNPRECEDENTED DISASTERS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ARE PARTNERS
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
BECAUSE THEY HEARD OUR PLEA AND
WE AT REACTED QUICKLY SOMETHING
HAD TO BE DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
SCHOOLS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
RESTORING NORMALCY TO CHILDREN'S
LIVES IN ADDRESSING TRAUMA YOU
FOR THAT TODAY.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION SOME UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT IN URBAN
WILDFIRE CAN CAUSE AND POSE FOR
SCHOOLS AND SOME POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS YOU SHOULD CONSIDER.
ONE PROTECT SCHOOL FUNDING.
AFTER CRISIS CONSISTENT FUNDING
IS MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER TO
HELP SCHOOLS REBUILD.
THANKS TO THE ACTION ON THE PART
OF THE LEGISLATION CREATED TO
HOLD HARMLESS AND AB UNDER THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT.
SONOMA COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICT
WERE PROTECTED LOSING FUNDING IF
5% OR MORE OF THEIR HOUSING
STOCK WITHIN THEIR BOUNDARIES
WAS LOST.
HOWEVER IN LOOKING CLOSER AT THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY WE FOUND THIS DID NOT
APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
WERE IMPACTED.
ONLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
PERSONAL THE COUNTY THIS LIST
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT AREAS
INCLUDING COFFEE PARK AND MARK
WEST WITH FUNDING DECREASES TO
AREAS SERVED BY THEIR DEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO DEVELOP A
STANDARD STATUTORY LANGUAGE
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
CODE TO HOLD HARMLESS ALL LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES INCLUDING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND COUNTY OFFICES.
IN FUTURE NATURAL DISASTERS.
THIS IS NEEDED UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF SUCH DISASTERS ARE
BECOMING NORMAL.
RE OPENING SCHOOLS.
I ALSO URGE YOU TO DEVELOP A
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOL FOR RE
OPENING A SCHOOL SITE AFTER THEY
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY TOXIC
FIRES.
THEIR PROTOCOL THREE OPENINGS
SCHOOL SITES AFTER EARTHQUAKE
HAD BEEN LIVED THROUGH THAT.
BUT PRIOR TO OCTOBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TUBS FIRE NONE WERE IN
PLACE FOR RE OPENING SCHOOLS.
THE SITES THAT WERE IMPACT I
THINK YOU HEARD FROM THE STATE
TODAY THEY CREATED SPECIAL TASK
FORCE TO WIN OUT TO OUR
DISTRICTS.
AND EVALUATED BECAUSE DISTRICTS
STAND LOCAL JURISDICTION THE
ONLY THE LOCAL SUPERINTENDENT
CAN DETERMINE WHETHER RE
OCCUPANCY IS NOT AS LOUD.
THE TUBS FIRE A SPECIAL TASK
FORCE WAS CONVENE BY THE CD AND
CAL -- YES
AND WAS HELPFUL IN ASSISTING
THESE LOCAL DISTRICTS FIND A
SOLUTION AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
KEEP THIS TYPE OF STATE TASK
FORCE IN PLACE AND READY TO
MOBILIZE IN FUTURE DISASTERS.
AS WELL GUIDANCE IS NEEDED FOR
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
REGARDING TOXIC ASH AND HOW IT
SHOULD BE DEALT WITH.
AIR QUALITY GUIDELINES.
LIKE Y. STANDARD GUIDANCE IS
NEEDED TO HELP SCHOOLS DETERMINE
WHEN TO CLOSE AND HOW TO ENSURE
STUDENT SAFETY WHEN AIR.
QUALITY IS HAZARD.
AFTER THE CAMP COVERED A LARGE
REGION FOR MORE THAN A WEEK IN
CINEMA COUNTY.
THIS PUTS SCHOOLS IN THE
CHALLENGING POSITION OF TRYING
TO ACT AS PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
IN DETERMINING WHEN IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO KEEP SCHOOLS OPEN.
IN SPEAKING WITH AIR QUALITY
EXPERTS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS.
MY OFFICE LEARNED THAT SCIENCE
AROUND AIR QUALITY FOR URBAN
WILDFIRES IS STILL EVOLVING.
THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT OVER THE
BEST AIR QUALITY MONITORING SITE
TO USE WHETHER IT IS BETTER TO
KEEP SCHOOLS OPEN OR CLOSE NOT
ALL AIR QUALITY DISTRICTS ARE
EQUAL.
AND WHETHER TO HAND OUT MASKS OR
NOT.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONVENE
EXPERTS IN PEDIATRIC HEALTH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THEIR QUALITY
DETERMINE A STANDARDIZED SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
FOLLOWING.
WHAT AIR QUALITY MONITORING SITE
SHOULD BE USED WHEN IF EVER
SCHOOL SHOULD CLOSE DUE TO POOR
AIR QUALITY?
MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS CHOOSE TO
STAY OPEN BECAUSE THEY SAW IT AS
AN EQUITY ISSUE. TO PROVIDE
CLEAN AIR AND ENVIRONMENT AND IT
JUST TO DO IT TOO IT'S
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS.
HOW TO EQUIP SCHOOLS WITH
FILTRATION SYSTEMS THAT ARE GOOD
FOR AIR QUALITY THEY WOULD LIVE?
ENSURE GOOD AIR QUALITY.
WHEN CAN SCHOOLS EXPECT TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR CLOSING DUE TO
AIR QUALITY CONCERNS?
SHOULD AND IN NINETY FIVE MASS
BE DISTRIBUTED TO CHILDREN AND
OR EDUCATORS.
WE HAVE RECEIVED CONFLICTING
INFORMATION FROM MULTIPLE
SOURCES ON THESE QUESTIONS.
THE COUNTY OFFICES LEAD AGENCY
COUNTY OFFICE TO SHOULD BECOME
THE LEAD AGENCY FOR PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS DURING AND AS
DISASTER.
SCOPES NUMBER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ACTED IN THIS ROLE TO
THE CATHOLIC DISS TO THE SEVENTH
DAY ADVENTIST.
CHARTER AND SCHOOLS THAT WERE IN
BOTH OF THOSE TO RELIGIOUS
SCHOOLS LOST THEIR SCHOOL SITES.
TOTALLY TO THE GROUND. ONE OF
THE SOME OF SCHOOLS IMPACTED THE
CATHOLIC THAT'S WERE ST ROSE --
CARDINAL NEWMAN.
AND THE ARE SLIM CAMPUS WERE
GONE.
WE DID PAPERWORK FOR BOTH PROPER
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
WELL FILE RECOVERY TOOL KIT
UNFORTUNATELY THE LIKELIHOOD OF
A SIMILAR DISASTER IMPACTING
OTHER EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITIES IN
THE MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD IS
VERY HIGH.
OUR OFFICE ALL FOUR OF OUR
OFFICES ARE WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION. TO
DEVELOP A TOOL KIT FOR COUNTY
OFFICES THEY CAN BE USED IN
FUTURE WILDFIRE FIRES.
ANCHORAGE LEGISLATURE TO WORK
WITH THE CSS CSS ARE
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATION IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH A STATE TOOL
KIT [inaudible]
MENTAL HEALTH.
THE MENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS OF A
TRAUMA SUCH AS A FIRE ARE FAR
REACHING AND LONG LASTING.
CINEMA COUNTY SCHOOLS ARE STILL
DEALING WITH STUDENT AND STAFF
WHO HAVE BEEN TRAUMATIZED.
WE WERE FORTUNATE TO BENEFIT
FROM GRANTS THAT ALLOWED US TO
CONTRACT WITH EXPERTS IN PROVIDE
TRAINING AND RESOURCES TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND FAMILY.
NOT EVERY IMPACTED COMMUNITY.
HAS BEEN THIS LUCKY.
I WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IT WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL OF CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DIVISION
WHICH PROVIDE A LINE OF SUPPORT
TO SCHOOLS TO ASSIST THEM IN
DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES.
ADDRESSING STUDENT AND TEACHER
TRAUMA WILL IN IT WILL ENABLE
OUR COMMUNITIES TO HEAL AND OUR
STUDENTS TO THRIVE AND DEVELOP
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU WAS VERY CAN [inaudible]
MEREDITH.
CHARO DONNELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO PROVIDE LITTLE
INPUT ABOUT OUR LOCAL
LANDSCAPING EXPERIENCE.
ENTER COUNTIES HOME TO TWENTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
WOULD SERVE NEARLY HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND THEY ALL VERY WIDELY IN SIZE
AND STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS. ONE OF
THESE JUST TORY BOTH IN LOS
ANGELES AND INVENTOR COUNTIES
AND IS LOCATED PRIMARILY IN THE
CITIES OF CALABASAS AGORA HILLS
WESTLAKE VILLAGE AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS.
ARE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
KAMALA VALLEY UNIFIED IN THE
THOUSAND OAKS NEWBURY PARK AREA
AT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THE SMALLEST SANTA CLARA
ELEMENTARY WITH FIFTY SEVEN
STUDENTS IN A LITTLE RED
SCHOOLHOUSE ON HIGHWAY.
ONE TWENTY SIX DURING THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
WE'VE EXPERIENCED NOT ONE BUT
TWO WILDFIRE EVENTS.
THE THOMAS FIRE WHICH BEGAN ON
DECEMBER FOURTH IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND THE WALLS IN HILL
FIRES WHICH STARTED ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTH. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
GATHER THESE TWO DISASTERS
ACCOUNTED FOR THE DESTRUCTION OR
DAMAGE OF ALMOST THREE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOMES
[inaudible]
THANKFULLY.
NONE OF THE SCHOOL SITES WERE
BURNED.
BUT I WOULD REMISS BE REMISS IN
NOT ALSO.
REMINDING EVERYONE OF THE THIRD
OF THAT DISASTER WHICH BEFELL US
IN THOUSAND OAKS WITH THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTINGS --
THAT HAPPENED AT THE SAME TIME
AS THE WILL SEE AN HILL FIRES.
YOU CAN'T PUT A PRICE TAG ON
THAT.
DURING THE THOMAS FIRE ALL
VENTURA COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WERE CLOSE AT LEAST ONE DAY
WHEREVER THEY WERE LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
BUT VENTER UNIFIED --
THE MOST SEVERELY AFFECTED WAS
CLOSE FOR FOURTEEN SCHOOL THE X..
THAT BACK RIGHT UP AGAINST OUR
WINTER HOLIDAY SO SKILLS WERE
OUT OF SCHOOL.
FOR A PERIOD OF NEARLY FIVE
WEEKS.
AND IN MANY OTHER DISTRICTS
THERE WERE CLOSURES OF THIRTEEN
TWELVE TEN EIGHT SCHOOL DAYS.
DEPENDING UPON CONDITION LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND SOME DISTRICTS
CLOSED RE OPENED AND THEN CLOSED
AGAIN.
BASED UPON CHANGING AIR QUALITY.
MORE THAN A YEAR LATER.
IN THE VENTURE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. FIVE SCHOOLS WERE
CLOSED BECAUSE OF THE THREAT IN
THE RECENT RAINS OF DEBRIS FLOW
BECAUSE BY THE THOMAS FIRE OR
SLOPE MOVEMENT.
BECAUSE THE LAND IS SO SATURATED.
OVER THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
LOST THEIR HOMES IN THIS FIRE
AND THE REMEDIATION OF THE
FACILITIES EVEN THOUGH THEY
WEREN'T BURNED.
REQUIRED FROM THE IMPACT OF THE
SMOKE.
WROTE MADE US DO EXTENSIVE
CLEANING REPLACEMENT OF ALL OF
OUR HVAC SYSTEMS.
IN THE MORE RECENT WILL THE
INHALER FIRES THE CANAL UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS CLOSED FOR A
PERIOD OF SEVEN FULL DAYS.
AND FIVE OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE SURROUNDING AREA CLOSED.
FOR FIVE SIMILAR CHALLENGES WITH
REGARD TO AIR QUALITY STUDENT
HEALTH AND THE REORGANIZATION OF
ALL OF OUR TRANSPORTATION ROUTES
ALSO OCCURRED.
THOSE ALSO CAME WITH PRICE TAGS.
IN BOTH OF THESE EVENTS ARE
OFFICE WAS ABLE TO SERVE AS A
PUBLIC CLEARING HOUSE FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT SCHOOL
CLOSURES FOR ALL OF THE ELLIE
ETS.
AND THIS INFORMATION PROVED TO
BE SUFFICIENTLY VALUABLE AND
RELIABLE.
THAT THIS VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE --
DIRECTED THE PUBLIC TO OUR
WEBSITE WE ALSO DID HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE IN THE LOCAL EOC.
THE ALSO COORDINATED THE DAILY
PHONE CALLS WITH DISTRICTS
SUPERINTENDENTS TO DISCUSS THE
AIR QUALITY IN SCHOOL CLOSURES.
AND OUR SPECIAL POPULATIONS
DEPARTMENT ALSO PROVIDED SUPPORT
TO THE MARGARET COMMUNITIES
WHICH WERE IMPACTED BY THE
THOMAS FIRE.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT SOMETIMES
GET FORGET FORGOTTEN ABOUT.
IN IN EVERY INSTANCE WHEN WE
THOUGHT ABOUT.
KIDS COME TO SCHOOL KIDS SAFETY.
SAFETY ALWAYS TRUMPED LEARNING
IN THIS CASE.
AND FROM THE OUTSET STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES CAL
FIRE IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WERE VERY QUICK TO OFFER THEIR
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE.
AND THESE ARE PLEDGES WHICH
CONTINUE TO EXIST TO THIS DAY.
A GREAT MANY THINGS WENT RIGHT
DURING THESE DISASTERS AS A
RESULT OF THE COLLABORATIVE
CULTURE.
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR COUNTY
[inaudible]
NONETHELESS PERRANCE. TO
CONTINUE TO REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT MISS LEARNING.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
WE WERE ABLE TO OPEN THE SCHOOLS.
THE AMAZING THING IS THAT BOTH
THE STUDENTS AND THE STAFF COULD
NOT WAIT. TO GET BACK TO NORMAL.
SO WITH REGARD TO POLICY CHANGES
OR INITIATIVES GOING FORWARD.
COULD OFFER THE FOLLOWING --
PROBABLY THE MOST COMMON
QUESTION THAT I WAS ASKED IS.
ARE WE GONNA MAKE UP THE DAYS.
AND I SAID I'M SORRY.
WE'RE GOING TO ME WITH MADE
WHOLE BY THE DAYS THAT WE LOST
THROUGH A WAIVER PROCESS.
BUT THERE IS NO MECHANISM NOR IS
THERE AND IDENTIFIED FUNDING
SOURCE TO BE ABLE TO RESTORE THE
LEARNING. FOR KIDS THAT MIGHT
HAVE ONLY GOTTEN A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX OUT OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS BECAUSE OF AN
UNFORESEEN DISASTER.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT I KNOW IT'S A HEAVY LIFT.
THAT COMES THAT'S THAT'S A LOT
OF MONEY.
ALSO ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
MEET EMERGENCY WAIVERS THAT
AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE ASKED FOR
OR WAITED FOR TO OCCUPY NON
DIVISION OF THE STATE ARCHITECT
APPROVED FACILITIES.
IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
QUICKEST RETURN TO OUR KIDS
LEARNING.
AND ALSO SOME PROVISION WITHIN
THE STATE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DIDN'T EXPECT TO
HAVE TO REBUILD THE SCHOOL OR
RECONSTRUCTED SCHOOL.
AND WE'RE NOT IN LINE FOR
FUNDING THROUGH THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD.
I BELIEVE THERE MAY BE SOME
EMERGENCY FUNDING THERE BUT TO
PUT IT AT A HIGHER PRIORITY.
ON THOSE THAT WERE AFFECTED BY
SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER THAN
THEMSELVES WOULD BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL.
AND ALSO --
AS DR HARRINGTON REFERRED --
TO IS ALSO SERVE STUDENT
POPULATIONS IN MANY CASES WE
SERVE THE MOST AT RISK AND NEEDY
POPULATIONS MANY SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATIONS.
BUT WHEN WE LOSE STUDENTS THAT
DON'T COME BACK AFTER A DISASTER.
WE DON'T GET A GRACE PERIOD LIKE
REGULAR SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO TO
EASE THE BURDEN OF LOST
ENROLLMENT.
WE THINK THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD DO WE COULD BE ADDED TO
THAT POT --
AND AGAIN --
THERE'S MUCH MORE TO BE SAID BY
MY COLLEAGUES AND MUCH THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD TODAY.
OF EXTREME VALUE AND I THANK YOU --
AND FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THESE REFLECTIONS THANK
YOU.
MISS FLORES.
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU.
SHASTA COUNTY IS HOME TO TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS IN A
COMBINATION OF TWENTY FIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SEVENTY
FIVE SCHOOLS. 70% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE WHITE WITH OUR
LARGEST ETHNIC GROUPS BEING
HISPANIC AND AMERICAN INDIAN.
LAST YEAR WE HAD 57% OF OUR
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH.
A CAR FIRE WHICH BEGAN ON JULY
TWENTY FOURTH AND DIFFERENT FROM
THE OTHERS WAS SUMMER --
TOOK THIRTY EIGHT DAYS FOR A
100% CONTAINMENT. FOUR OF OUR
SCHOOLS THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
LOST WERE SAVED BECAUSE THEY
BECAME THE HOME BASE FOR THOSE
FIGHTING THE FIRE.
BECAUSE SHASTA COUNTY IS AN OPEN
ENROLLMENT COUNTY.
THE THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
EIGHTH GRADE OUR KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE STUDENTS
WHO LOST THEIR HOMES ACTUALLY
HAD ATTENDED FORTY FIVE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS IN THE PRIOR
YEAR.
WHISKEYTOWN ENVIRONMENTAL SCHOOL
HAS PERMANENTLY CLOSED AFTER
FORTY NINE YEARS OF PROVIDING A
WEEK LONG ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE TO FIFTH
AND SIXTH GRADE STUDENTS IN THE
NORTH STATE DUE TO THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DEBRIS FLOW.
FROM HEAVILY BURNED AREAS THAT
SURROUND IT.
DAMAGE AT THE SHASTA ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BECAUSE THE SCHOOL TO
RELOCATE FOR SIX MONTHS AND THEY
PLAN TO RETURN ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A FEW
BEST PRACTICES THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF OUR EXPERIENCE.
THE DAY AFTER THE FIRE CAME INTO
READING IN OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
SERVICES DIRECTORS DEVELOPED --
PLAN CONTRA CONTACTING THE TO
CHILD CARE.
AND CENTER BASS LICENSE
FACILITIES ARE DIRECTORS PULLED
THE LICENSE FACILITIES LIST
MAPPED THE EVACUATION AREAS AND
STRATEGICALLY CALLED PROVIDERS
IN THE DANGER AREA FIRST
OFFERING SUPPORT AND SERVICE
COORDINATION.
STAFF COLLECTED INFORMATION IF
PROVIDERS WERE EVACUATED LOST
THEIR HOME OR BUSINESS IF THEY
WERE OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
HOW MANY CHILDREN THEY COULD
SERVE AND THEIR CURRENT
ENROLLMENT?
WE USE THIS INFORMATION TO LINK
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN NEED OF
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE SERVICES
AND KEPT COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF ED INFORMED.
IN ADDITION WE CONTACTED
FAMILIES IN SUPPORT OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CHILDREN SERVE
THROUGH OUR SUBSIDIZE CARE
PROGRAMS WHO LIVED IN THE CAR
FIRE AFFECTED AREAS.
OFFERING SUPPORT IN LOCATING
ALTERNATIVE CHILD CARE
COMPLETING CAL FRESH
APPLICATIONS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY KNEW TO GO TO THE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE CENTER WHEN IT
WAS OPENED.
EVEN THOUGH THE FIRE BEGAN IN
THE SUMMER WE BROUGHT TOGETHER
DISTRICT IN CHARTER SCHOOL
LEADERS TO SHARE WITH THEM
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF ED
PARTICIPATED IN OUR INITIAL
MEETING VIA PHONE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS RIGHT AS THEY AROSE.
AFTER THAT DAY AND FOR THE NEXT
MONTH WE SENT OUT A DAILY
BULLETIN TO EDUCATIONAL LEADERS
COMBINING ALL OF THE INFORMATION
IN ONE PLACE THAT WE HAD LEARNED
THAT DAY.
SOME INFORMATION CAME THROUGH
THE COUNTY EMERGENCY SERVICES
COLLABORATORS MEETING THAT I
ATTENDED.
OTHER INFORMATION CAME THROUGH
EMAILS AND PHONE CALLS.
OUR OFFICE COMBINED ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IN TO ONE GOOGLE DOC
IT TO SEND AT THE END OF EACH
DAY AND THE COMMUNICATION MATH
AND WAS WELL RECEIVED BY ALL OF
OUR LEAGUE ARE EDUCATION LEADERS.
WHEN THE LOCAL LISTING CENTER
OPENED OUR OFFICE MADE IT A
PRIORITY TO ACCURATELY CAPTURE
STUDENTS?
CHILDREN FROM ZERO TO AGE
EIGHTEEN WHO LOST THEIR HOMES IN
THE FIRE TALKING WITH EACH
FAMILY THAT CAME THROUGH.
THE LOCAL IS SINCE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER.
WE CREATED THAT MASTER LIST OF
OF INCLUDING THOSE WHO WERE IN
CHILD CARE.
IT CHILD CARE CENTERS THOSE IN
PRESCHOOL THOSE ACROSS K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
AS WELL AS HELP TO REGISTER
FAMILIES FOR CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL
AND EMERGENCY CAL FOR ASH
VOUCHERS.
THIS TOOK THE BURDEN OFF OF ALL
THE SCHOOLS THAT WERE IMPACTED
AND CREATED A MASTER LIST OF
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
WAS HELPFUL IN KEEPING.
IN SCHOOLS INFORMED IN THE DAYS
AND WEEKS AHEAD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT TO
CHALLENGES OUR SCHOOLS FACED IN
WHERE WE COULD USE YOUR
ASSISTANCE.
THE FIRST CHALLENGE IS IN REGARD
TO THE FIELD ACT REQUIREMENT
WHICH MANDATES EARTH GROUP
EARTHQUAKE RESISTANT
CONSTRUCTION OF SCHOOLS.
BUT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE LOCATED WITHIN
BUILDINGS THEY HAVE THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS.
BECAUSE OF THE DAMAGES SHASTA
ELEMENTARY THEY HAD TO RELOCATE.
AND AS THEY LOOKED AT BUILDING
AFTER BUILDING NONE OF THEM MET
THIS CRITERIA.
AS A RESULT --
I REACHED OUT TO LIVE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF ED IN
QUESTION WHY AN EMERGENCY OTHER
SCHOOLS COULDN'T BE GIVEN THAT
SAME FLEXIBILITY THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE TO BE IN A NON
FIELD ACT BUILDING.
AFTER THE DECISION WAS REACHED
TO MOVE THE ELEVEN CLASSROOMS
FROM SHASTA ELEMENTARY INTO
SEVEN OPEN SPACES AT ANOTHER
SCHOOL ABOUT TEN MILES AWAY.
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
CAME OUT THAT ALLOWED FOR USE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE OF A NON
FEEL THAT BUILDING BUT AT THAT
POINT WAS TOO LATE THEY HAD
ALREADY NOTIFIED PERRANCE.
THE SECOND CHALLENGE IS
TRANSPORTATION AND YOU'VE HEARD
THAT ALREADY THIS AFTERNOON.
SHASTA COUNTY IS A LARGE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA COVERING OVER
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES.
VERY FEW FAMILIES LEFT THE
COUNTY AFTER THE FIRE BUT
STUDENTS WERE SPREAD THROUGHOUT
FOR EXAMPLE ONE DISTRICT THAT
WAS HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THE FIRE
HAD ONE FAMILY RELOCATE WITH
RELATIVES FORTY MINUTES AWAY
FROM THE SCHOOL.
STILL IN SHASTA COUNTY.
AND WITHIN THE MCKINNEY VENTO
ACT HOMELESS STUDENTS HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO REMAIN IN THE SCHOOL
OF ORIGIN DURING THE TIME OF
THEIR HOMELESSNESS OR AND FOR
THE REMAINDER OF THE ACADEMIC
YEAR.
THE SCHOOL I WAS REFERENCE SEEN
IS A SCHOOL OF FORTY STUDENTS
ACROSS KATE EIGHT AND SO THE THE
COST FOR THAT TYPE OF
TRANSPORTATION IS DRAMATIC.
SO TYPICALLY WITHIN THE SCHOOL
YEAR EIGHT THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS STUDENTS IS SMALL BUT
WITHIN THE CAR FIRE SOME SCHOOLS
SAW THE NUMBER DRAMATICALLY RISE
WITH NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO
SUPPORT THIS NEED.
AND SCHOOLS TYPICALLY PAY FOR
THE COST OF HOMELESS
TRANSPORTATION OUT OF TITLE ONE
DOLLARS THAT THEY RECIEVED.
BUT THIS EXCEPTIONALLY LARGE
COSTS FOR TRANS TAKE IT AWAY
FROM READING AND MATH
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE TYPICALLY
USED FOR THIS FUNDING.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE SO THAT OTHERS CAN
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCE AND
POTENTIAL CHANGES CAN BE MADE TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRE IN THE FUTURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE HEARD HOW ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS PRIVATE SCHOOLS
IN BUTTE COUNTY WERE DECIMATED
BY THE CAMPFIRE ON A MEMBER
EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE
IMPACTED BY SCHOOL CLOSURES.
AND FORTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
WERE LEFT HOMELESS.
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED SCHOOL
STAFF MEMBERS FROM AROUND BUTTE
COUNTY HAVE ALSO LOST THEIR
HOMES.
OUR ROLE AS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION IS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
TO ALL SCHOOLS AND ALL STUDENTS
IN OUR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS OUR JOB TO
ADVOCATE FOR SCHOOLS.
COMMUNICATING UNMET NEEDS UP THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND THROUGH AN
INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE.
INCLUDING OUR OWN THE INCIDENT
COMMAND HAVE.
AN IN COORDINATION WITH THE
JOINT SCHOOLS TASK FORCE.
OUR COMMON MESSAGE IN BICU
COUNTY WAS LET'S REUNITE OUR
STUDENTS WITH THEIR TEACHERS.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE DEPLOYED
A NUMBER OF RETIRED AND ACTIVE
ADMINISTRATORS AND CONSULTANTS
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH SCHOOLS
AND DISTRICTS. TO SUPPORT THEIR
VARYING NEEDS INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS NUTRITION.I. T. FACILITIES PLANNING FISCAL
RECOVERY AND DONATIONS
MANAGEMENT.
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION ALSO
NEEDED TO BE GIVEN TO OUR EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS ARE PRESCHOOLS
CHILD CARE NEEDS AND OUR
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS.
AND TRULY IN BUTTE COUNTY.
IT WAS VICTIMS HELPING VICTIMS.
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
STATE RESOURCES THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO ACCESS INCLUDING THE
GREAT SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
CAL O. E. S..
OTHER COUNTIES COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
OUR SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR OWN
ASSEMBLYMAN JAMES GALLAGHER AND
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR ORGANIZING
THE VISIT OF POST FIRE OF THE OF
YOUR CALL X..
SPECIAL THANKS ALSO GO TO OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS INCLUDING CAL
FIRE BUTTE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE C. H. P. AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGH
MUTUAL AID.
AND WE ARE ALSO SO VERY GRATEFUL
TO OUR PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS ACCENT
CSPA CASTRO AND THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
AS FOR AREAS OF POLICY WE ARE
ASKING AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY ASKED. FOR ON GOING
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING AND
SUPPORTS.
IN BUTTE COUNTY WE ALREADY HAD
THE HIGHEST ACES RATE PRIOR TO
THE FIRE.
AND NOW ARE MOST IMPOVERISHED
RURAL STUDENTS HAVE BEEN RE
TRAUMATIZE HAVING SUFFERED
THROUGHTHIS MAJOR LIFE CHANGING
EVENT.
BC -- WE
IMMEDIATELY DEPLOYED TEAMS OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
POSSESS BUT AS OUR COLLEAGUE
MICHELLE JOHN NOTED EARLIER IT
SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE HAVE COORDINATED RESPONSE AND
TRAINING THAT'S ON GOING WE HAVE
BROUGHT IN WORLD RENOWNED
EXPERTS TO SUPPORT US AND TO
HELP TRAIN THE TRAINERS.
BUT THIS IS A MARATHON IT IS NOT
A SPRINT.
NBC -- HE IS
DEDICATED TO HELPING TO LEAD THE
WAY WITH YOUR HELP.
WE CONSIDER OURSELVES TO BE
AMONG THE RURAL EXPERTS AND
WE'RE INTERESTED IN HELPING
OTHER RURAL AREAS AS WELL.
IT IS ARE RESPONSIBLE
RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN T. K. THROUGH.
TWELVE AND TO ALSO OFFER SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORTS FOR
CHILDREN AGES.
ZERO TO FIVE WE ARE ASKING FOR
FUNDING STABILIZATION FOR OUR
MOST IMPACTED SCHOOLS.
FIRST FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AT MINIMUM. FOR ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE ARE ALSO ASKING THAT FOR YOUR
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION FOR TINY
GOLDEN FEATHER UNION ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IRONICALLY
IS A BASIC AID SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THAT RELIES ON DIRECTLY RELIES
ON PROPERTY AND YET IS AMONG OUR
MOST IMPOVERISHED COUNTY EXCUSE
ME COUNTY SCHOOL.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE ASKING FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT PROTECTION FOR THE
CELL BY A SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREA FUNDING THROUGH
A BEAT.
SIX OH TWO AND OF COURSE CLASS
SIZE FLEXIBILITY.
AND AS WELL AS CONSIDERATION FOR
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF FEMALE
HOUSING IN OTHER DISTRICT
LOCATIONS.
AND PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT
BICU COUNTY HAS YET TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS ANY OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS SUCH AS THOSE PROVIDED
OTHER COUNTIES THROUGH PROJECT
SURF.
IN REGARD TO FACILITIES NEEDS WE
ASK FOR TEMPORARY FACILITIES
WAIVERS THROUGH.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY DURING THIS TIME OF
CHANGING REALITIES.
AS WELL AS ASSISTANCE AND ADVICE
WITH CLEANUP DEMOLITION AND TREE
REMOVAL FOR THOSE ITEMS THAT ARE
NOT COVERED BY INSURANCE.
OR CALLOW WE AS DEBRIS REMOVAL
PROGRAMS OR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
FROM FEMA.
AND FINALL WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER BUTTE COUNTY AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS. FOR HELP AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF LOCAL PRE
APPRENTICESHIP APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FOR BOTH SHORT AND LONG
TERM TRAINING NEEDS.
WE ESTIMATE THAT OUR AREA HAS
LOST AN ESTIMATED SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE LOCAL GDP.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT OUR BUTTE
COUNTY RESIDENTS HAVE THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY FOR RETRAINING AND
JOB PLACEMENT IN THE REBUILDING
EFFORTS.
BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IS COMMITTED TWO LEADING THE WAY
AND BEING ACTIVE PARTNERS WITH
OTHER EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND ACTIVELY
TRAINING AND FINING PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR LOCAL
FOLKS AND THAT WORK HAS ALREADY
BEGUN.
THE DAUNTING TASK OF REBUILDING
OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES LIES
AHEAD OF US.
YES WE ARE BUTTE SCHOOL STRONG.
BUT PLEASE CONSIDER HELPING US
IN PROVIDING OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
COUNTY OFFICES WITH THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO RECOVER
[inaudible]
REBUILD.
AND REIMAGINE THE FUTURE FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU THIS PAN
LINED UP.
ANOTHER SOME QUESTIONS I JUST
ALSO MAKE SOME COMMENTS QUICKLY --
I HAVE A LIST OF THINGS I HEARD
HIM THAT I'M NOT GOING TO READ
IT ALL OFF.
BUT THE PROTECTING SCHOOL
FUNDING THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS IN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THEY'LL HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO BE MONITORED.
AND WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE TWO
YEARS OUT THREE YEARS OUT AND
THEN EVEN LONGER YES.
THE TIME FOR THESE GUYS IN A
LONG TIME FOR SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES TO REBUILD THE A
FUNNY INTERACT WITH THAT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS BECAUSE THE
STUDENT NUMBERS WILL DROP BUT
THEN THEY MIGHT SPIKE AT SOME
POINT.
TOO SO THAT IS TO BE A
CONVERSATION WE HAVE TO HAVE --
THE RE OPENING A REAL OPENING
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOL AQM DIS
ACROSS THE STATE AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S A MILITARY
THAT -- WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT WITH
THAT APPROACH BECAUSE LA IS SO
BIG.
RIGHT AND AIR QUALITY OVER HERE
IS THE SAME AS THE AIR QUALITY
IS OVER THERE SO HOW DO THEY
MAKE THAT CALL WHAT KIND OF
MONITORING TO THE EMPLOYEE.
IF WE ARE TO HAND IT OVER TO THE
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT'S SO THAT'LL BE A
CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE MAKING THE COUNTY'S LEAD.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T ALL AIR
MONITOR ASH IN ASH DEBRIS.
CAM.
SO FOR THE COULD GET ALL AIR
QUALITY CONTROL BOARDS.
UTILIZING THE SAME AIR QUALITY
MONITORING SYSTEM MY COUNTY IS
DIVIDED IN HALF.
SO IT'S LIKE HOW DO YOU GET A
GOOD READING AND IF YOU GO TO A
COMMERCIAL LIKE PURPLE AIR.
THAT'S LOCAL PEOPLE PUT THAT IN
THEIR HOME JOURNAL WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED.
BUT WE CAN'T EVEN GET A
CONSISTENT BETWEEN THE TWO OKAY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WE HAVE
TO HAVE AND I LIVE IN AN AREA
WITH A LOT OF OUR MIND AIR
QUALITY.
MANAGEMENT GOING ON BECAUSE I
HAVE TO PORTS SMATTERING OF FIVE
MILES AWAY THERE'S A WIND BLOWN
OF THE OCEAN VERY CLEAN AND THEN
IT'S NOT A PARTICULAR MATTER IN
THE AIR.
OTHER TOOL KIT --
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE THE SUIT STATE
SUPERINTENDENT COULD ACTUALLY
TAKE UP THAT TASK.
AND AND WORK WITH YOU. TO DO
THAT TO BE INCLUDED.
OKAY.
OKAY SO YOU DID NOT DID YOU
STILL NEED. TO DO SO SO.
WHERE DOES NOT APPLY TO YOU AT
ALL NO?
OKAY.
EXECUTIVE ORDER PLAY BUT IT
DIDN'T APPLY FOR FOR HOUSING
FLEXIBILITY OKAY SO THE FEEL THE
FEEL THAT REQUIREMENTS WERE NOT
WAY BEARD IS YOU KNOW THEY WILL
YOU STILL NEED THAT WAIVER --
WE'RE WE'RE MANAGING TO GET BY
WITH PRE EXISTING BUILDINGS.
BUT THEY DO HAVE THE YOU DID GET
THE WAIVER AND UNDER THAT WAIVER
WAS HE WAS DOWN THERE A WEEK --
THEY HAD BEEN LOOKING.
FOR WE GET HOUSING IT WAS AFTER
A WEEK THAT THE SCHOOL HAD BEEN
IMPACTED BEFORE THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER CAME THROUGH FAMILIES WERE
ASKING YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
SO THEY HAD.
GONE AROUND AND LOOKED AND IT
WAS -- IF I
RECALL A WEEK I I DID BRING THE
DATE WITH ME BUT I THINK IT WAS
ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER CAME THROUGH.
IN THE BILL THAT WAS INCLUDED
FOR YOU YES AND UNDERSTAND --
IN THE MAKE UP DAYS THAT'S AN
ISSUE I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THEN WITH REGARD TO SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM I SIT ON THE
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD.
AND I KNOW WE JUST DID SOMETHING
FOR PARADISE RECENTLY I'M SURE
IT'S NOT ENOUGH I'M QUITE
CONFIDENT OF THAT --
SO THAT'LL BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION LOST EIGHTY A AGAIN.
AND OTHER DONATION MANAGEMENT I
HEARD THAT A LOT OF THE IN
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW. SIX SEVEN HAVE YOU A
BAG FULL OF GIVE CARDS YEAH YEAH.
AND I GET WHY THAT WOULD BE AN
ISSUE AND HOW DOES THAT I'LL GET
THAT I DON'T KNOW THOSE ARE ONLY
LOCAL PROTOCOL SO THERE'S SOME
STATE ACCOUNTING.
MECHANISM YOU'RE SUPPOSED
EMPLOYED BUT THAT'S INTERESTING --
TO SO WITH THAT THANK UNITED
NOTE JUST REAL QUICK CHáVEZ
JOHNSON YOU ONE OF THESE ARE THE
COUNTIES WE HEARD FROM.
THE LOCALS WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
DID YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING OR
DO THEY COVERED ADEQUATELY.
OR DO YOU WANT TO DIFFER FROM
THEM YOU CAN DO IT NOW.
NOW IS YOUR TIME [inaudible]
THE COVERED.
IT JUST JUST TO JUST THREE THE
THEM FEDERALLY HAS NOT COME IN
YET.
NOW FOR THE YOU.
KNOW HOW MANY RESERVE FEDERAL
AID IS I'M SORRY WE HAVE
RECEIVED OUR FEDERAL YEAH.
WELL MISTER GALLAGHER THE TRUMP
YOUR GUY SO ONCE YOU TAKE CARE
OF THAT.
GET ON THAT [inaudible]
THE RESULT.
I HAVE A QUESTIONS MORE LOCAL
HERE MY DISTRICT IS IS JUST TO
THE SOUTH OF THAT MISTER
GALLERIES DISTRICTS SO MY ISSUES
SOMEWHAT PALE IN COMPARISON TO
THE GREAT TRAGEDY.
WE SAW BUT IT REYES AN
INTRIGUING QUESTION QUESTION
THAT.
THESE THESE FIRES SHOES --
IS COULD BE THE NEW NORMAL AND
WE COULD HAVE MORE ME MORE AND
MORE OF THESE AND THERE IS JUST
GREAT CONFUSION.
IN SOME OF THIS LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ABOUT WHAT TO DO.
AND THE THE PARTICULATE MATTER
WAS WAS OFF THE CHARTS --
I READ ONE DAY HERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF SACRAMENTO IT WAS IT
WAS THE WORST IN THE WORLD THAT
DAY.
AND IT WAS IT WAS WORSE HERE
THAN IT WAS UP IN --
PARADISE SURPRISINGLY --
JUST BECAUSE OF THE THE WIND
PATTERNS AND THE GEOGRAPHY OF
SACRAMENTO OR IN A BATHTUB
PRETTY MUCH IN THE VALLEY SO MY
QUESTION IS.
IS -- SHOULD
WE SEE WE HAVE THE STATE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF A STREAMLINED
APPROACH TO WHAT TO DO IF HE'S
EVER HAPPEN AGAIN FOR OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS HERE.
IN THE SURROUNDING AREAS WHAT TO
DO STAND HOME DON'T GO WE HAD
CONFUSION ABOUT THE DAY CARE
MASK ANONYMOUSE BUT JUST FOR THE
KIDS IN THE FAMILIES --
YOU KNOW WE HAD OUR OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER SAYING ONE THING.
OUR CONTROL OFFICER SAYING
ANOTHER THING OUR SUPERINTENDENT.
YOU KNOW VALUE ANYTHING'S AND
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE --
THE BEST APPROACH SO SO GOING
FORWARD WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
HELP I'M LOOKING INTO THIS ISSUE
I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAYBE --
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS AS WELL.
WELL I THINK THAT LA IS
CONCERNED BENEFIT FROM
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ON WHAT TO
DO -- WE ARE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO HAVING A
DISCUSSION WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
THE LOCAL AIR QUALITY ON
DISTRICTS TO SEE WHAT COULD BE
DONE TO PROVIDE THAT GUIDANCE
FOR THE ONLY ACE.
BUT BUT I AGREE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CERTAINLY HEARD AS A
CONCERN THAT THERE WASN'T --
SUFFICIENT GUIDANCE FOR FOR THE
LA SPIELEN MAKE THE LOCAL
DECISIONS.
SO DO YOU ANTICIPATE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING FORWARD
FROM THAT.
STATE DEPARTMENT OF ADAM WHAT WE
SHOULD DO GOING FORWARD.
LEAVING THAT TO US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE WE WILL BE
INITIATING CONVERSATION WITH
YOUR RESOURCES BOARD. TO SEE IF
WE WILL HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
WE'RE CERTAINLY ARE GOING TO BE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR A
PRESENTATIONS.
WILL PUT GO TO PUBLIC COMMON IF
YOU COULD LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS.
TO A ONE MINUTE. TO BE
APPRECIATED.
YOU WANT ME TO GO HEAD.
YES TRY TO BE VERY BRIEF --
OR PRESSED IN WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AS YOU HEARD FROM
OUR INCREDIBLE MEMBERS YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON AND I I WANT TO
ADD A COUPLE THINGS THAT THEY
DIDN'T TOUCH ON ONE IS THE
DASHBOARD.
AND WE HAVE A SUPERINTENDENT I
WORKED WITH REALLY CLOSELY AND
YOU CRIER SHE SAID I COULD USE
HER DISRUPTING.
THE LOSS TO STUDENTS --
PEOPLE LOST THEIR HOMES THEY
REALIZED I MEAN IT'S ONE OF THE
SO TENNIS IS STILL INCLUDED IN
THE DASHBOARD FOR ALL OF THESE
DISTRICTS.
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE --
THAT IS TO BE ADDRESSED IN A
GOOD POINT --
AND THE TRAUMA AND I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T SAY THIS IT
NUMBER ONE IS IT IS WORKING WITH
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR OUR OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR PARENTS AND
COMMUNITY BUT I'VE LISTENED TO A
NUMBER OF OURS SUPERINTENDENTS
TALK AND THEY'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING FOR THEMSELVES.
AND SO WE YOU KNOW AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THEM JUST
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
CONSIDERED A PRINCIPLES ARE
SUPERINTENDENTS IN ANY KIND OF
TRAUMA THAT IT ON CARE THAT'S
BEING GIVEN.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT I GUESS
IS THE LAST OF ONE LASTING
SOMEONE MENTIONS IS THE CLASS
SIZE REDUCTION WAIVER BECAUSE
WHEN YOU DO HAVE STUDENTS
LEAVING --
ONE COMMUNITY IN GOING TO
ANOTHER SAME WITH YOUR TEACHER
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS --
FOR MISS ASSIGNMENTS DOES NEED
TO BE WAIVED AS WELL AS I'M IN
IN THE SORT OF SITUATION SO WE
CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF ON A
MANY OF THESE SORT OF IDEAS THAT
HAVE COME FROM OUR MEMBERS.
AND THE HE THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THE ALSO THAT CAME UP WERE
DISTRICTS THAT REMAINED OPEN
THAT HAVE A HORRIBLE AIR QUALITY
AND SO WE HAVE DECENT THESE
STORIES WHICH IS THE FIRE
BURNING SCHOOLS AND BRING HOMES
BUT THE IMPACT FOR THE FROM THE
SMOKE HAS BEEN VERY.
EXTREMIST AS ALL OF YOU KNOW SO
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS REMAINED
OPEN SO THAT THEY CAN FEED THEIR
KIDS -- AND
YET THEY DON'T GET ANY
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE LOS EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT OF THE PARENTS WHO
DECIDED TO KEEP THEIR STUDENTS
HOME. TO THE AIR QUALITY AND THE
SAME GOES FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT
SHOWS TO CLOSE --
AND THEN THERE'S THE WANT TO
FEED THEIR STUDENTS AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING REIMBURSEMENT I KNOW
THAT'S A FACT AS WELL.
SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE GONE ON THAT ARE JUST
OUTSIDE OF WHAT YOU WOULD EVEN
CONTEMPLATE THAT.
WOULD BE --
SOMETHING THAT OUR EDUCATORS ARE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH AS ONE OF
OUR SIX SAID LAST WEEK SHE SAID.
DORMANT TRAINS YOU FOR THIS AN
ADMINISTRATION SCHOOL SO --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOUR YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
MINUTES CASEY TAYLOR I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A CHIEF
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN PARADISE WE
OPERATE A K. EIGHT IT'S BEEN
OPEN SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND A BRAND
NEW HIGH SCHOOL IN PARADISE THAT
JUST OPENED THIS FALLING
COMPLETELY BURNED TO THE GROUND
IN THE CAMP FIRE.
ON BEHALF OF THE SIX PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT WERE
OPERATING IN PARADISE AND
SERVING A THOUSAND OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THAT
COMMUNITY BEFORE THE CAMPFIRE.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT ALL SIX
OF OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS FOUND
TEMPORARY SITES IN CHICO AND A
COLLECTIVELY SERVING MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DISPLACED STUDENTS IN CHICO.
WHILE THE BUTTE COUNTY CHARTER
LEADERS ARE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER QUICKLY WITH THE BUTTE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
GET STUDENTS BACK INTO SCHOOLS.
AND REESTABLISH THROUGH THE
ROUTINES THE TASK OF GETTING
STUDENTS BACK ON TRACK WILL BE A
LONG PROCESS REQUIRING
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS WILL
NEED TRANSPORTATION RESOURCES AS
OUR FAMILIES ARE SCATTERED
ACROSS BUTTE COUNTY WE NEED
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
AND SUPPORT FOR ACADEMIC
INTERVENTION AS THEY AND THEIR
TEACHERS ARE JUST NOW WITH.
ENTERING A PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
AND MENTAL SPACE TO LEARN AND
TEACH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICK
RUBINO AND FROM 200-012-22000
SIXTEEN I SERVED AS A
SUPERINTENDENT IN YOU COUNTY THE
GREATLY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I CURRENTLY SERVE AS AN
EDUCATION CONSULTANT FOR FORTUNE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION WHICH IS A
K. TWELVE CHARTER SCHOOL NETWORK
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ON THE
MORNING OF SUNDAY NOVEMBER
EIGHTEENTH.
AT SEVEN THIRTY IN THE MORNING I
RECEIVED A DESPERATE CALL FROM
THE FORMER BUTTE COUNTY SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT TIM TAYLOR --
REQUESTING MY ASSISTANCE AS PART
OF A TEAM TO COME AND ASSIST THE
SIX PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM
PARADISE. TO FIND A LONG TERM
TEMPORARY FACILITIES IN CHICO
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THREE WEEKS WE
HAD ACCOMPLISHED OUR TASKS.
I HAVE TO REQUEST FOR YOU FIRST
pDAILY ATTENDANCE PROTECTION.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THE
UNSETTLED LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
HAVE FAMILIES LIVING ALL OVER
THE REGION AND SECONDLY.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR TEMPORARY
TRANSPORTATION RESOURCES TO
CONNECT THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
LIVING IN PLACES LIKE OR A BILL
DURHAM READING --
EMMA GALIA TO GET TO THE LONG
TERM TEMPORARY LOCATIONS IN
CHICO AND THEN EVENTUALLY WHEN
RESETTLEMENT HAPPENS IN PARADISE
TO GET THOSE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
SETTLED IN CHICO. TO GET BACK TO
THEIR SCHOOL COMMUNITY THANK YOU
IN PARADISE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING EDUCATOR VOICES IN THE
CONVERSATIONS TODAY --
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THE STATE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
HUNDREDS OF HEROES THAT YOU HAVE
IN EDUCATORS THAT HAVE LITERALLY
SAVE STUDENTS LIVES ALL OVER THE
STATE WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE CONTINUED STABILITY.
SO THEY CAN HEAL AND THEN ALSO
HELP OUR STUDENTS TO HEAL SO
WE'D LIKE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THREE YEARS
TO HOLD HARMLESS ADEQUATE IN THE
CASE OF PARADISE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH FISCAL
STABILITY TO GET THEM THROUGH WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ISSUES LIKE
TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE WE'RE
FINDING THAT THE LACK OF
SUFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
IS ACTUALLY BECOMING AN
IMPEDIMENT TO HELPING THE
DISTRICTS MAINTAIN THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE SERVICES TO ALL OF THE
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO ATTEND THEIR SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO WANT TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HEALING
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM SO MEANT TO HELP FOR
EDUCATORS TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
SO THAT THEY CAN IN TURN MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS RETURNING
TO THE CLASSROOM HAVE THAT
STABILITY IN CAN MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRENDAN TO A GUN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF THAT'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS --
WE ARE VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD AND
WOULD BE.
HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN --
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT CD AND
CARBON OF COURSE --
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ANOTHER
LEGISLATORS --
WE DO SEND ADVISORY SET OUT TO
THE PUBLIC --
INCLUDING SCHOOLS --
WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE IMPACT
THAT THE AIR QUALITY HAS ON ON
CHILDREN AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA SHIP AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD --
THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD CURRENTLY
HAS A PETITION BEFORE US
REQUESTING EMERGENCY STANDARDS
TO ADDRESSED NON EMERGENCY FIRST
AND THAT'S NON FIRST RESPONDER
WORKER EXPOSURE. TO HAZARDOUS
AIR QUALITY CONDITIONS I'D LIKE
TO ECHO MISTER HARRINGTON'S --
EXPERIENCE THAT.
THE STAND THEY EIGHT Q. WHY IS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE PELS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY USED TO
ESTABLISH --
PARTICULAR MATTER LEVELS AND SO
IT IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED WE AT THE
STANDARDS WERE VERY CONCERNED
WITH WORKER SAFETY OBVIOUSLY NOT
INCLUDES THE PUBLIC.
TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE GROUPS THAT ARE
INVOLVED AND SO PLEASE KNOW THAT
WERE OUT THERE WERE THINKING
ABOUT IT WORKING ON IT.
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL --
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MIGHT
PATTERSON I'M --
PROUD TO SERVE ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I ACTUALLY
REPRESENT TEACHERS BOTH IN.
SHASTA AND YOU COUNTY AND TWENTY
ONE OTHER COUNTIES OF BUT THAT'S
NOT REALLY IMPORTANT HERE I JUST
WANT TO THANK.
EVERYBODY FOR THE HEARING
INCLUDING THE VOICE OF OUR
EDUCATORS FROM --
FROM UP THE HILL.
AND WE'RE DELIGHTED WITH THE
FACT THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE BE
HELD HARMLESS FOR TWO YEARS BUT
IN PARADISE THAT IS NOT GONNA BE
ENOUGH -- SO
PLEASE CONSIDER THAT FORWARD.
IT ALSO OUR EDUCATORS NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE JOBS TO
REBUILD THE SCHOOLS AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THEMARE
LOOKING FOR JOBS I'VE BEEN ASKED.
IN MY TRAVELS TO FIND WHICH
DISTRICTS HAVE.
LESS RESTRICTED RULES AS FAR AS
A NUMBER OF YEAS EXPERIENCE YOU
CAN BRING WITH YOU BY A LOT OF
OUR EDUCATORS IN PARADISE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
STAY EMPLOYED UP THERE TO
REBUILD THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SO
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO HELP WITH
YOU.
CAN DO IS HELP THAT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MIKE GROWING PRESIDENT
OF THE PRODUCTION FIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE EDUCATED
REFER FROM THE MINISTER'S ARE
SCHOOL BOARDS.
ARE THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
ARE NOT JUST THE EDUCATIONAL
ONCE IT'S NOT JUST [inaudible]
IT'LL.
THE DOOR HOME GM PRODUCTION ONE
OF THOSE THAT LOST THEIR HOUSE.
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
REPRESENTED TO OUR CITIZENS. TO
OUR KIDS.
WE'RE THE ONES THAT MAKE THE
DECISIONS.
THAT HAVE TO BE MADE.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT WITHOUT
THE RESOURCES.
AS WE LOOK AT TRANSPORTATION
WHICH IS A KEY ONE FOR US.
HELLO HOW DO WE GET ALL OUR KIDS
WERE THEY NEED TO BE FOR THE OUR
I WANT TO THANK.
THE STATE FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE HOW THEY HAVE HELPED US
FEMA FOR ALL THEY'VE HELPED US
TO GET OUR SCHOOLS OPERATING.
UP THE GALIA.
WITH CEDAR WOOD PINE RIDGE AND
FOR THE EVER SO MAKING JUST
FORCED TO GO AHEAD AND OPERATE
OR TOLD PEOPLE OPEN UP OUR HIGH
SCHOOL.
WITH A IT'S SOMETHING THAT AS A
SCHOOL BOARD PRESIDENT I'M ALSO
A FORMER TEACHER.
CGA MEMBER.
AN I APPRECIATE THE THINGS OF
THE TO LOOK IT UP BUT WE DO NEED
MORE THAN THE THREE YEARS.
PARADISE WILL NOT BE REBUILT
WE'LL I DON'T EXPECT OUR TENDS
TO GO UP. FOR FIVE TO TEN YEARS
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
HE MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER STEVE
HENDERSON REPRESENTING SUCCESSOR.
I JUST WANT TO ADD TO WHAT --
DR HARRINGTON SAID EARLIER WE
HAVE DEVELOPED A WILD FIRE AND
DISASTER RECOVERY COMMITTEE --
AND WE'VE TAKEN OF
SUPERINTENDENTS THEIR
EXPERIENCES TO HELP DEVELOP THIS
MANUAL FOR OTHER COUNTY OFFICES
SO THAT THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER THESE
TYPES OF THAT DISASTERS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
PRESENTED TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS INTO DEAL
WITH THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS --
THIS HEARING WE OF COURSE TO A
LOT OF OUR MEMBERS WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS LIKE A LOT
OF FOLKS AND SO --
WE APPRECIATE THIS ALSO WANTED --
TO EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT THAT THAT WERE MENTIONED --
FROM A SCHOOL FACILITIES
PERSPECTIVE --
AND THAT WAS --
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT DEALING
WITH SOME OF THIS DEBRIS IN THE
TOXIC DEBRIS AND THEN CERTAINLY
THE AIR QUALITY ISSUES WHICH HAS
BEEN -- WELL
COVER WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT
AND AND ALSO THE GENTLEMAN JUST
MENTIONS THE SOME KIND OF GOT
MORE GUIDANCE THAN WE HAVE OF
COURSE WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
SO --
KASTEN'S READY --
TO OF OUR OUR EXPERTISE --
IN OUR RESOURCES AS WE GO
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS MARK LEACH I WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I REPRESENT --
THE TEACHERS OF ME THE TEACHERS
A PARADISE PLUS TEACHERS FROM TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WELL --
I'M HERE --
TO ASK FOR READ MORE RESOURCES
IN A LONG TERM FORMAT --
SO THAT THESE EDUCATION
FACILITIES HERE THESE ELEAZAR
CAN.
PROVIDE AN EDUCATION THAT IS
SUPERIOR. TO THERE ARE
NEIGHBORING --
COMMUNITIES THAT'S HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO DRAW THE PEOPLE BACK
AND CONTINUE TO KEEP THE
STUDENTS ENROLLED AND US BE
LEADERS IN.
REBUILDING THE COMMUNITY OF
PARADISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
EVERYBODY HERE TODAY.
AND VERY INFORMATIVE HEARING AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT --
THIS TOPIC BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY.
WE NEED MORE CONVERSATION AGAIN
THANK YOU